[Music]
hey what's going on it's finally Friday
night yep God damn it yeah we're not
going out so we're just going to Usher
you into your weekend so we can get as
drunk as we want yeah we're good drunk
for a while I haven't went I even went
down earlier and had to get a whole new
bottle of vodka cuz we were almost out
like it's like 5:00 and I kind of walked
through the living room and I was like
oh [__] we only like that much AA left
and I'm like that's not acceptable so I
had to go and then I I went to get Tom
and he was taking a nap so I was like
well [__] I'll just go down and get some
got Sebastian in here got Danny murder
Hornet Zack York Rock D Vinci hey what's
going on you guys it's my favorite
Yorker Rock York is it yorar rock or
York rock yeah they're all start people
starting to come in yeah yeah they're
all hooray y okay I think this might be
my favorite show of the week to do cuz
it's low it's easy cuz it's low
stress although I will say just chitchat
get drunk yeah I mean you know I don't I
don't really have to like research
anything or anything like that which I
like which I like doing that but it's
just kind of like you know what I mean
on here we can just talk about whatever
I was going to say I was telling him
before the show started um I'm actually
really proud of how our dragons show
came out Wednesday night I was like
because I covered everything I wanted to
cover I think I got like all the
information and I thought it was really
interesting and I think we stayed on
topic about 80% of the time yeah which
is which is a really good you gave me
heads up you had a [__] ton of [__]
information so I I I I stopped I made
sure I wasn't common but the thing about
it is that even when we went off on
tangents it was still like about
mythology you know what I mean so it
wasn't that far off it wasn't like we
were just like talking about three hour
show I think it ended up being almost 4
hours but but like I said I covered
everything I wanted to cover and I was
just cuz I was really charge them extra
for that I was going to say I was like I
was really stressed out beforehand
because I spent like almost two entire
days like researching that show because
there's so much stuff about it that I
had to like winnow it all down and like
put it in a framework that you know made
sense and was like interesting and stuff
because there was a lot of tons of other
information that I had to take out so I
was like stressing out about it but you
know what I mean but it came out good
and so I was like really happy and like
it seemed like a lot of people commented
that yeah they really liked and they
wanted more like stuff like that yeah I
didn't realize how many dragons there
were in Greek mythology M it just I
didn't recognize them as dragons yeah
that's what they were dragon is a
serpent so everything that was a serpent
Hydra yeah cuz that's what the word
started out meaning so it didn't like
mean the whole like game of Game of
Thrones situation like until later on
right so yeah that's what it was and
that K that would Kad was a dragon yeah
oh Zach says uh so guess how my day
started was hung over and had to pee
real bad toilet's clogged oh my God I
hate when that happens uh I go to unclog
it damn thing overflowed all over the
floor damn should have just pissed down
a
sink or in the shower
yeah I mean that's what I would have
done I'm like [__] this [__] this got to
go now yeah yeah Zach said and this was
before i' even had breakfast or coffee
see oh that sucks man yeah I've been
there I've had that same exact thing
happen one time we had a toilet back up
on us at the old place for no reason at
all just flush the toilet and Water
started coming out of the damn where the
the like from underneath underneath the
toilet yeah it it was like fresh water
it didn't Snak but it was filling up the
whole bathroom we were just throwing
towels trying to figure out what had
happened and I just plunged it plunged
it plunged it and I heard something go
Brook out of the [__] big uh uh uh
bathtub that we had at the old place and
then the big garden tub yeah then it it
all went down it was kind of weird it
was I think it was some kind of blockage
that was like near where the washing
machine drained out yeah I think that's
where the blockage was yeah the water
yeah that that water may have been come
from the washing machine I don't know
yeah because it's like I mean at least
smell like sewage yeah at least thank
God that it was just water like it it
wasn't just it wasn't like horrible
sewage but yeah but yeah it just kept
coming and I was like oh no it's like
just coming out all over the [__]
bathroom floor no real reason that we
can see yeah there wasn't anything like
clogging the toilet in there it was in
the plumbing someplace else the plumbing
in that place was so weird it was on
like two different yeah circuits because
like one half of the house cuz that
house was just one story like one half
of the house seemed to have its own
little piping situation going on and it
was fine but then like our side where
our bedroom was um was the same same as
the washing machine thing so I think
when something blocked like near the
washing machine like it backed up into
the tub and everything like that they
were real pretty houses in a in a real
nice uh gated community uh look like
something out of you know I would make
videos outside about what about my bu
and [__] and some of my friends uh in
Brazil who were who had bus would
[__] go God damn look at that look at
that neighborhood because they don't
have anything like that Brazil and then
they were say it looks like part of
Disneyland cuz some and they were like
yeah it kind of it kind of is it does
yeah you know and and it's everything
kind of looks like that around here in
certain areas well the new stuff looks
like something belong to Disney
Empire but um the houses looked real
pretty but they were built very quickly
yeah and out of and kind
of the things like the [__] faucets
and the handles and door knobs on things
they were just kind of cheap yeah and
there's no telling what how well thought
out the plumbing was because it didn't
seem to work I think not very I don't
think they really thought it out too
well even though they're asking like
$400,000
$500,000 those houses um I think that
one was 375 I think yeah and like I said
that was much smaller than this house
but um this one was 475 that one with
that that house we lived in was what it
was four
bedroom yeah three and a half bath yeah
but the bedrooms some half the bedrooms
were very small were really small like
one of them I just used for my office I
would call it a two-bedroom [__] like
the master bedroom was real big like it
was big enough for like a bedroom and
like a living room thing walking closets
and it had its own bathroom it was
enclosed it had a garden tub and a
standup shower like separate which I
thought was neat it was nice and it had
like a huge walk-in closet which I
really liked the bathroom area was the
size of an of a lot of rooms yeah it was
big like a bedroom yeah like it had this
big long like double sink and yeah all
this other stuff bad we didn't get to
make any porn in that that was a porn
that was a porn set [__] just too
late now we can't go by well our
landlords live there now they live there
now because that was the the house they
owned but yeah redoing the Landscaping
out here yeah that's what that's what
Tom's been working on the last few days
got a guy helping me lay it out and
everything tore out a bunch of well
there was a bunch of Shrubbery in front
of the house I cut out [__] five and
we cut them all down I cut out five huge
bushes and then I had to hire a guy to
come and [__] grind the stumps out
yeah and then uh just finishing up and
it's [__] pansy
ass after uh Christmas he's going to
come and he's going to [__] lay it
out he's got a design I'm not a I'm not
a landscaper just paying for him to
design it I'm going to buy the trees and
[__] from him and I'll put it in there
uh but when it when it's in the value of
the house should go up it already did go
up I think I've made 25,000 on this so
far yeah just just because the how much
was this when we bought it 4 475 75 it's
500 now okay but like I I mean but this
is a big I don't even remember what the
exact um yeah what the exact square
footage is if I keep 4,000 something if
I keep working on it and fixing on it
with because this is now becoming a an
area where they're building they're
building all kinds of [__] around here
yeah they're building [__] around here
it's rural but it's not going to be for
long I'm hoping that in 10 years this
might be an $800,000 house yeah maybe we
can like sell it and make yeah I would
just sell it I would sell it and then uh
pocket the rest of
it I mean maybe so we might be able to
yeah cuz like I said this is a big I
mean yeah it'll be older but this area
is building up and the thing about it is
that I was going to say one of the it's
not that old yeah it's not this one of
the things the only thing I didn't like
about the old house was that the houses
in that neighborhood they were all
really pretty but they were kind of too
they were too close together right on
top each other they were too close
together like we could look at our
bedroom window and like our neighbor's
window was like right there like 10 ft
away yeah this this is on an acre land
but yeah this house like yeah we've got
lots of neighbors it's a big
neighborhood but everybody has Big Lots
yeah and well in this part in this part
of the community yeah it's not an this
is not a gated community but it should
be it was built to be one yeah you can
just drive in it's it's got two
entrances a front one and a back one but
you has own has its own restaurant too
yeah it's got it own restaurant it's own
Golf Course doesn't have its own gym and
it doesn't have its own pool which it
should yeah that kind of
sucks the two entrances are built to
where there's an in lanane and an out
lane in lanes and out lanes so they can
put guard T guard booths there and Gates
which eventually is going to have to
happen because they keep robbing cars
they keep hitting the cars here yeah
there have been a lot of cars broken
into in this neighborhood because I'm on
the next door like neighborhood thing
and it's like people are always pissing
and moaning about I'm just like lucky
for me nobody wants my [__] car cuz
it's a piece of crap and there's nothing
in there that you would want we just
leave it open I just leave it open I'm
like take it I'm insured you know what I
mean yeah but I'm going to buy a car
here soon yeah once chance well you
might have to keep that in the garage I
just I just parked mine out on the
driveway got yeah but then I got those
generator in there I got that ride on
lawn mower motorcycles where I'm going
to put all this [__] that's true but if
we do we don't the garage is not big
like our old house had that was another
thing we had two garages at that we had
a two-car garage and then like a little
onear garage that had like you know the
blond Mower and all that other [__] in
I'm and motorcycles I'm going to make
room for stuff I got going to have
to cuz I don't think I can leave that
car outside probably not well not with
all of the car robberies going going on
unless I got bad ass alarm on it my [__]
never gets broken into because my car
looks like ass I'm going to get she's a
good car though I've decided I want to
get a Kia Soul yeah we were talking
about that yeah I like I like that I dri
I drove one and I liked it yeah you rent
you drove one when you went to
Mississippi your dad right you rented
one yeah and I said man I only get one
of these cars it's just like a little
bitty van it's size of it it's the size
of a small car but it's kind of
tall yeah I kind of like the idea of
having something that's like a car but
also has like a little bit of like an
SUV kind of s cuz I don't really want an
SUV cuz I'm I don't like driving
anything that big it's like a SUV the
size of a compact car yeah see I like
that idea and it had a lot it had a good
back seat in it it had a nice little
trunk and it was kind of reminded me of
a deluxe Jeep like a like you took a
Jeep and built it on of car chassis that
what it was like but it had a real good
sound system and it was uh it was fast
and Nimble for something that looks so
lame they look kind of lame they're very
boxy like a box but I still liked it I
think they're kind of cute though I'm
not I'm not one of those people that
it's like I'm not super concerned about
what the car looks like um I just want
something with good gas mileage that is
practical for my lifestyle um if it
looks kind of wonky or people think it's
lame or something I don't really care
about that I don't care it doesn't
matter
but uh every now and then you I was
checking you can get
them maybe 3 years old with 40,000 miles
on them for about 15 grand here 16 Grand
and uh that's about right I'm not going
to pay [__] 25,000 30,000 for a new
car no especially with what they're
offering these new cars they're not all
that great it's much better to get one
that's just a few years old couple years
old yeah because if you buy a new one I
mean they lose like a
in first or so you might as well just
get one that's a years I want something
that got repossessed off somebody they
couldn't afford it you know what I mean
lost their job and it's got [__] 40
Grand on it 40,000 miles I I get a
better deal with something like that
yeah that's what I mean and all the new
electronics and everything are so much
better than what we're used to it's got
[__] GPS is built in and your [__]
sound systems got Bluetooth got the
backup cameras you got backup cameras
which is nice I could use that yeah cuz
[__] man my car is an old ass basic as
[__] for taist from 2004 like a teenager
in that thing nothing it has nothing it
has a tape deck when I was a teenager
that car was [__] Hightech Robo
RoboCop was driving one in the movies
and I said boy that's a futuristic ass
car but now man [__] [__] they're
kind of a heavy
slow ponderous kind of car for its size
you know and they they don't get great
gas mileage
really here's V6 okay this is a V6 I
think I don't drive it a lot anymore so
right I just want something either like
a Honda Fit but those things are so
[__] expensive I liked my Honda Fit I
bought a new one in 2013 and it it was
really good I like imagine the
electronic packages are so much better
oh yeah it's much better that was the
first well first and only new car I ever
bought in my whole entire life her old
Honda Fit was fun to drive that [__]
was fast I mean I couldn't believe that
such a wimpy looking car I down it's
going like 120 on the free yeah see I
got to watch with that because I will
absolutely go 100 miles hour feel like I
was going
120 110 I think cuz I'm just like and
then I'm like oh whoops yeah was like
[__] four o'clock in the morning
coming back from the castle [__] goth
club was going heading towards
Orlando and [__] I said man this car
is [__] awesome man I love how it
rides cuz I was used to my [__]
[__] bombed out Mustang your Mustang
Mustang d d [__] that car was so low
to the ground and it was so heavy it's
like whenever I drove it it was like I'd
be going 60 MPH but it felt like I was
going 30 mes an hour cuz I kept like
pushing the gas going this is so slow
yeah it's an illusion but then when you
get up to 90 on on that old Mustang it
felt like you were going like 130 you
felt like you were going much faster
than you should have been because you
really were you were going too fast you
couldn't stop that car in time just it
just weigh so much I had a chick in
a I forgot what kind of car was it
wasn't it was a it was a little bitty
compact car she rear ended me and and it
[__] total her car crushed the whole
[__] front end and it barely knocked
a paint off the bumper that must and
she's like how come it didn't do any
damage and I says that's a [__] 94
1994 [__] for it's all it's all steel
yeah steel and plastic
yeah wait a lot but yeah she rear
endered to me at the light [__] it
just crushed the front her front end in
it was a what the [__] was I think it
might have been a
Mazda well they designed cars yeah more
recent cars they designed them to kind
of like crush the front end you know
what I mean like to prevent like people
from getting yeah like the car was still
running yeah and she's like the thing is
I don't have any insurance and my
license is oh well
and I was said well there's nothing you
can do about it so I just [__] tied I
tied her
um uh Hood down right she had a uh a
[__] a shirt a t-shirt in the back
seat and I tied it down and she was able
to drive away it was still running huh
but it was that's something but the the
[__] the radiator had moved about six
or seven inches to the rear and it had a
big [__] the [__] thing was flat
still running still running that's yeah
I looked at it it was just the the frame
and the thing that was holding the
radiator yeah and the bumper it mushed
itself in it didn't damage the the uh
the wheels or the the engine it it was
just like empty space it just crushed in
and um the body panels were like plastic
and the only the the the [__] Hood
was uh it was metal but it popped back
into shape and it no longer fit properly
so the the the the L the hood latches
could didn't line up anymore right you
know what I mean because the the bottom
latch had moved in about four or five
Ines and and she's going what do I do
and I I I tied it shut and I said you
should be able to find somebody around
here that can pound that front end back
out until the the latches line up and
the and the and the hood
will uh you know lock it didn't look
that bad right cuz you know the the a
lot of the the the quarter panels were
like uh
plastic so if the [__] metal frame
was put back in in in position the body
parts would go back to where they were
you know
yeah it was weird man the accident I was
in which
was it must have been
2014 I want to say 2015 cuz when I still
worked at that print shop cuz I got on
an accident on the way to work at that
print shop um and that was I was driving
my old Nissan Sentra it was a Nissan
Sentra yeah it was also old I think that
was also a
2004 and what happened was I went into
the turn lane the light was green you
know cuz I was turning right and the
people in front of me were turning right
and the light was green for whatever
reason the person not the person in
front of me there was an SUV in front of
me like a big one the person in in front
of that person um just stopped dead for
some reason I don't know why because
like I said the light was green and I
couldn't see that person stopping dead
because there was an SUV in front of me
and I couldn't see the car in front of
them so the SUV in in front of me
stopped dead and I rear ended that
person um I really didn't have time to
do much of anything except scream and
then I hit them um it crushed the whole
F fr end of my
Nissan and you know the um airbags came
out and
everything and uh yeah luckily I was not
hurt at all the car obviously didn't run
anymore but um and I didn't get charged
I didn't get blamed or anything even
though I was you know even though I had
rear ended them but I was just kind of
like yeah but the person in front of
them cuz the guy driving the SUV his was
the SUV wasn't even it didn't even make
a de like he's like basically all that
happened was his coffee went all over
the [__] cabin but you know what I
mean but that's all that happened he
wasn't hurt nothing and so um but they
were like yeah we didn't know why the
person in front of that person just like
stopped suddenly because the light was
green so I don't really know why that
happened but so I didn't really have a
time to stop but um yeah so grter is in
there what's up Grant he said the
average car note is now 700 a month yeah
I've been looking at what I'm looking at
you know which is like something under
15 that under 15 grand I can get what I
want for about 14 between 13 and 14 so
it would probably be about 300 and then
you got your insurance because of my age
and driving record and my credit and
everything probably cost about 400 a
month yeah you could get a good deal and
then me and J go half on it yeah because
it's going to be under your name cuz my
credit's not good yeah right so we're
going to put the car under his name when
we buy another one yeah I might might
not even put you on the insurance
because you won't be needing to drive it
I'm the one that's always drive it when
we go anywhere that's true I mean it's
it would be good for me to be on it in
case I needed to go someplace you know
like to visit my sister or if I needed
to go to the store or something like
that like when you weren't here Blue
Moon though and I think I you can drive
other people's cars yeah you can so
every time we go anywhere we work from
home yeah so our insurance will be cheap
I'm retired and you're working from home
so there's no commute we got great
driving records I sh perfect yeah even
with those [__] sport bikes P perfect
so yeah you haven't even been in any
well I mean you've been in a couple
wrecks nothing involving another vehicle
but nothing involving another vehicle
yeah because the the motorcycle wreck
you were in that was just you just me
yeah cuz you hit a cat
unfortunately but um but yeah I've only
been in one accident and like I said
nobody was hurt my car was totaled but
nobody else and they never [__] with me
for
speeding see I got I understand the cop
me mentality see Grands that's my buddy
and there to school together he's a cop
he's he's he's an ex
cop first of off I know what I'm doing
on a motorcycle and I dress like I know
what I'm doing I'm wearing all [__]
gear motorcycle gear armor helmet
[__] [__] tons of [__] wear damn
racing suit racing I would worry a lot
more about you if you didn't wear all
your stuff I wear a two-piece I don't
wear the one piece but I wear a
two-piece so the cops don't even check
me they go ah he cuz I don't know what
it is I guess they cops like safety gear
and they like [__] that looks
professional NE you're on there with a
[__] wife beater a cigarette holding
out no
helmet flipflops they're coming after
you well probably justifiably because
they know you don't you've never been in
a wreck you don't know what the [__]
you're doing you're care yeah you're
ripe to [__] wipe out and kill
yourself sure so they'll just [__] pull
you over to [__] try to save your
life because you're a [__] idiot yeah
you know I'm wearing full body armor and
[__] [__] that [__] it's all black
with [__] white [__] Pegasus wings
on the back and [__] helmets and
[__] armored gloves and [__] and uh
they just look at my license plate they
see that the shit's [__] up to date
and they go yeah he's good and and
they've seen me speed but it's
never triple digits you know it's the
same as the way cars speed here car
speed I can't really I can't really
criticize because I I always yeah car
speed here the speed the legal limit if
I get away with it the legal limit here
is 70 miles an hour 80 is real
common but on a highway now you're in
the 45 Zone you can get away with 55 on
a motorcycle you might get away with a
little bit more depends on also depends
on where you're at if you're in a bad
neighborhood they're going to pop you if
you're in a good neighborhood they just
let you go
yeah obv endangering yeah those cops the
cops in the good neighborhoods here are
[__] well fit
they're well fed well paid and they know
the locals and [__] they're probably
like man I just want to sit in my car
and eat my eat my they're trying to
they're not making their money off fines
yeah that's not how that you know in
some of the in some of the real more
rough areas fines are a huge um source
of income to keep the there's not much
tax revenue
there so they find
people that's really what I was talking
about when I grew up in an in
Brazil the police in third world Nations
they're runers an anarco tyranny is what
they are the police are not there to
stop crime because they're not going to
stop crime they're not getting paid
enough they don't give a [__] about that
they're there to write fines and tickets
they're the quality of the [__]
police in a third world or developing
Nation or just a [__] a tyranny which
is what Brazil was was the quality of
the police is like underneath the
quality of a mall cop nobody wants that
job because if
you if they do try to enforce a law or
Save Somebody they're going to get in
trouble for shooting somebody so they
don't want to shoot anybody it's kind of
like what you're seeing around some of
these major cities now where like
Chicago and everything where New York
where the police are afraid to do
anything because they might go to
jail that's the way Brazil was so the
cops were is
useless and the streets were run by
organized crime cartels and ex military
militias guns were banned but they were
[__]
everywhere if the cops ever [__]
caught a guy who's drug dealer he had
guns they took the guns but they let the
drug dealer go then they gave the guns
or sold the guns to their friends in the
militias so that's why I hear a lot of
these American peoples talking about law
and Europeans talking about law and it's
like they're set on [__]
novice I was set on
Expert none of those rules that you come
up with actually
work any kind of laws you come up with
they well they don't work in a
[__] in a society that has low trust
which that's eventually what happens
everybody becomes crooked over time as a
civilization starts to decline it
becomes
like the star war the the Star Trek
Mirror Universe everyone is corrupt
everyone's on the take none of the laws
really work none of the rules
work I'm starting to see it
here so but it's funny you know a lot of
people are freaking out to me it's just
I grew up in it so it's just normal for
me I'm like yeah this place is like
Brazil now let going get some [__] U
ice want some ice um might as well
refill it while because it's almost down
at the bottom uh John Smith said
aesthetically I love the americ American
Hot Rod look shame they're rolling death
traps yeah I mean they do look cool for
sure uh Danny says all cars are 10 can
death traps without a roller cage yeah
they
are Zach says I don't exactly trust
myself to drive I don't either frankly I
mean I do but I'm always nervous like
every time and if we if me and him are
going somewhere together then he's
driving I'm not
driving um but I'm also thinking who can
afford a car anymore let alone all it
takes to maintain the upkeep for one
yeah they are kind of like I mean I've
been kind of Lucky with my old ass
shitty looking car um she hasn't really
needed a lot of stuff I mean obviously
you have to put gas in it and have to
pay insurance and stuff
but I haven't really had I don't you
know I don't really want to say anything
to jinx it but I haven't really had any
huge big expenses like since I've had
that like it it just keeps on it's got
little problems but nothing that keeps
it from running um like I said it looks
terrible on the outside and on the
inside like it just looks it just looks
like Tom's like he's like I we need to
get a new car cuz this is like
embarrassing at this point CU it looks
so bad but um cuz honestly it's silver
but the Florida sun has like cooked off
like large patches of the paint you know
what I mean and it's got like rust and
stuff like that cuz it's 2004 it's
really old so you know Theus but yeah
but it's still like I said it still runs
and it's been like probably the most
reliable car I've ever owned that yeah
that was the last year of the Ford
Taurus keep on trucking that you saw on
RoboCop it it had been around for like
20 years at that point yeah I'm just
I've never had a major problem with it
it got to the point to where [__] man
nothing would break on those things and
then every part any all the components
are in are very inexpensive you can get
them from AutoZone so you could keep
that car running for a long time yeah
and we have done like I don't remember
the last time that I had to like spend a
lot of money on that SP had to spent $20
for the switch to the [__] control
the yeah but $20 that's like not that's
that's it that's like the last major
expense no the last major expense we did
was uh replacing the air conditioning
compressor that's right that's right we
had to redo the compressor that was a
while back about a thousand for that
that was a while back but you can't you
cannot have a car in Florida without air
air conditioning it's not possible no no
it's just not possible the inside of
that car would rot yeah that too plus
you would just like die you would die it
would just stink constantly yeah and it
would and grow mold too yeah it because
you got to have something to dry the
interior of the car out yeah yeah like
it's Florida everything's damp yeah all
the time 100% humidity all year round
yeah pretty much better in the winter
but not much better it's not much of a
winter no not really it just gets down
in the it was kind of when I went out to
the liquor store at 5:00 it was kind of
nice it was cloudy yeah and so it was
kind of starting to get dark dark and it
was like it was pleasantly cool like and
it's been real windy like the last
couple days been real windy some was
talking about hot rods when I left what
what what was that what what did he say
oh just said that um did he like the
American Hot Rod look shame they're all
rolling death
traps uh
well he must be talking about the
original what you would call Hot Rods
like from the 60s and 70s that he's
talking about cuz he was saying too that
it's like um the 50s did have a whole
genre of music dedicated to car crashes
they did yeah yeah that was a different
era though um they weren't death traps
compared to the other cars that were on
the road they were just like the other
cars that were on the road at the time
cars back then didn't even have [__]
seat belts or nothing so the standards
were very different um we still we still
see those running around every now and
then we just saw one the other day
[__] remember that thing yeah that
hot rod exposed engine and everything
totally illegal but you can run it here
as a classic car the the cops aren't
going to [__] with you well they have
classic car shows here like a lot right
so so like weekends you'll be driving
around and then you see like all these
like old cars like from back from the
20s and [__] like that driving around
that have all been restored the the the
problem with them is that they were all
steel which made them very heavy didn't
matter how small it was or how wispy it
looked it was it was all
steel they had mechanical brakes they
weren't using hydraulic brakes so they
didn't have much ability they didn't
have much of an ability to
stop but they weren't fast either see
that's another thing people
forget Ford Taurus that's [__] 20
years old is much faster than those cars
yeah uh they weren't very fast and once
you did kind of do mods to make them
fast they were now under
break so they weren't really hot rods
they just looked cool yeah and they were
high rods in the context of the
time
um most of those American cars weren't
very high performance just follow Steve
McQueen and what he had when he was an
actor he was a race car driver he always
had the best of the [__] he had a lot of
money in his day and uh he was in the
California car scene and whenever a new
car would come out he'd buy it and then
he'd send it to a high performance shop
and have it [__] tuned and perfected
and the brakes replaced and he had
everything over time you could always
tell what the best car was for the time
if Steve McQueen had it you know you
look at what he
had even Ferraris and [__] weren't all
that fast when they first appeared they
are now but like I said the standards
are all very
different um the Mustangs weren't fast
by the day
standards now they got some [__] out
today that's pretty good the the new
[__] Corvettes are [__] blistering
fast the problem with the new Corvette
is that here in Florida whenever you see
one and you pull up next to it it's
always an old man driving it so that's
an old man's car you never see a young
guy in a
Corvette I mean it's like and it's like
a dude in his 70s or 80s and that [__]
he's waiting his whole life to buy that
car yeah so it's like until he can
afford it it's the old manad car of
Florida yeah um which kind of tarnishes
it the [__] the two best cars that
were considered to be hot rods that
still exist or the modern hot
rods Mustang GT or and the Cobra Edition
they're pretty good they're not as fast
as that Corvette though but they've got
that look and and the uh that Dodge
what's it called what's that thing
called [__] uh not the Viper no it's
got that flat front end on it oh I know
what you're talking about uh [__] yeah
what the [__] is the name of that thing
yeah a lot of guys buy those they're now
getting to where they're uh their old
ones out that that are all ragged out
with bad paint you can get them for
cheap now Dodge [__] um not the
Challenger the Challenger is a good one
but it's the it's the model underneath
the Challenger maybe it is
Challenger yeah it might be the Dodge
[__] wouldn't that be a good it had a
flat front end look should call a car a
[__] that would be really good the
Ford [__] yeah although out of the two
I'd probably take the Mustang I'd take a
Mustang GT over to [__] i' buy a car
that was called that yeah I mean you
know James says sorry haven't kept up
did the job in Orlando stop um charger
that's right yeah oh okay the charger
and the
Challenger yeah I think the Challenger
is faster it's the same car I think but
if I remember correctly but it's it's
souped up a lot the Dodge Charger it
it's has a real gangster look to it you
see a lot of [__] wanabe gangsters
driving those got the flat front end and
the [__] kind of low I think it's a
twodo looks good good looking car and
that has that American Hot Rod look to
it
oh but I was going to say that um I was
working in Daytona actually which is
about an hour from here um and I quit
that in like early September because I
just couldn't do the drive anymore it
was just too much so I've just been
doing like freelance Cobin [__] together
yeah and she's got a good another new
freelance gig that's uh we're just
waiting on it right now yeah yeah yeah
Wai to get final approval yeah it's a
it's going to be part-time but it's
going to be enough to pretty lucrative
yeah like it's pretty lucrative like
what they're paying yeah so that's going
to start soon too so I'm happy about
that and once she once she stabilizes
that we're going to get rid of that
galap we're going to get a new car don't
let her hear you say that we're going to
make that that that car is going to get
a new a good
home cuz like I said it still runs I've
never had a single problem with it I
don't think the door panels on the
inside are busted out yeah but like I
said it doesn't she doesn't look pretty
she's she's pretty ugly it needs another
paint job yeah like the indoor you don't
want to sink ,000 in a paint J every
time you close the doors the little
panels the little panels on the inside
like Fallout yeah like I said it's still
got a tape deck I have one of those
things that you get at AutoZone that you
put the tape deck you put the tape in
the tape deck and and then it has a a
wire that you hook up to your phone so
you can place Bodify or whatever like
over like through the speaker do I still
have to do that yeah it's so old it
doesn't even have a [__] CD player
it's [__] pitiful it is yeah it's
we're gonna get we're gonna get a new
and we shove to the club and that [__]
and I'm getting embarrassed it was it
was all right when it had paint on it
yeah but it in a period of about two
years the paint just [__] boiled away
yeah so it's got like big yeah yeah like
it's got like big missing big [__]
missing spots on the the the the roof
and the [__] Hood the PO the paint
has boiled off now I will note that it's
it's not as bad I would submit that if
you live in Florida don't get a red car
no it'll be pink and two years that's
the worst color to get the sun is just
going to bake that [__] right off unless
you have a garage to keep it in all the
time most people here tend to get like
white or silver or something like that
because or beige um you know just
because if you get like an actual color
it's just going to fade and it's going
to look like ass because the sun's just
going to cook it yeah if it's black it
that car is going to be so hot your AC
will not be able yeah you're going to
like it's going to be like a [__]
easy bake oven in there yeah you want
white or silver that's really what you
want this is a silver car and it still
cooked the paint off and it still cooked
the paint off it took a long time it did
yeah I mean it's an old car and to be
fair um we've parked it out in the
driveway for years and years it has that
car has never been garaged like we never
put it in the garage that car has never
been garaged in never room in the garage
that car is 20 years old it has never
been garaged no I don't think so I don't
think so and that was Forge stock silver
paint so that's saying something and
that paint was 20 years old but you know
yeah John Smith said James Dean's car
was called uh little bastard why is no
one called the car that yeah see I don't
know I'm sure like somebody will come
around to that Zach says no no no a Ford
[__] is something quite different to
what you're
thinking oh I'm sure it is I'm sure it
is John Smith said I subscribed to the
theory that no car can't be improved by
Flames up the side haven't seen that
paint job in a long time we saw one the
other day didn't we like on the way to
the on the way to the Chinese buffet
didn't we see a car with it was a uh
that was a like a classic car a Model T
I think was it yeah it was like a
because there was a car show going on it
was I don't know if it was last weekend
or the weekend before but there was a
classic car show going on around here
someplace because we kept seeing them on
the road
Oracle said so the tourist will be going
to a farm
upstate yeah she will eventually but
like I said I can't complain I mean that
has easily been the most reliable car
that I've ever owned yeah and we bought
it used we bought it for what $1,00
something like that
$1,400 yeah we just bought it off put
new tires on it a random dude changed
the ignition had a roach
infestation hey who is that is that
Bryce thank you I think it's a Titanic
discussion okay discuss something I
can't see the end part but thank you
very much that's very generous we're too
old our Visions bad well no I can see it
it's just it doesn't have it all the way
on there because it's too long uh it
says greetings Jenny and Tom and
everyone do you think a new car styled
like a 50s belir with modern technology
would be a hit thanks and have a good
night maybe so I mean it might stand out
enough yeah I don't know it could be a
kind of thing do you remember like back
in the day when they did what was that
car that kind of looked like an old 20s
gangster car um about the PT Cruiser the
PT Cruiser yeah um and when that came
out like I don't think it lasted I think
it was just like hot for a minute and
then for but yeah they were around for a
while because they looked so much
different than everything else and I
think there is some value in that
because some people would be like man I
want something that looks distinctive
that was Chrysler's answer to the VW
Beetle that was coming back yeah and
actually a lot of people made fun of the
PT Cruiser and people that owned them
made fun of PT Cruisers but they were
pretty reliable once they got it right I
think the first year of it had no
problems but then they they update never
buy something in its first production
year there's
always um because I knew people that
owned them and say yeah I got one of
those [__] PT cruises it's still
running you know like they were like
wanting it to break we never had one my
dad had a Chrysler for a long time
though and he really liked them so he
had a Chrysler what the [__] was this
car it wasn't a PT Cruiser it was a
Chrysler or something the B air if I
remember if I'm imagining the the the
car you're talking about from the 50s it
was a [__] big land
yacht we still have something kind of
like that it's called a uh Lincoln Town
Car what do those look like nowadays I
haven't seen one in a long time they
look just like just like a [__] Crown
Victoria like a Ford Crown V oh okay
Ford Ford Crown
Victoria that's was like your standard
cop car your standard [__] heavy duty
Taxi they would uprade them into the
Mercury model I think it was called
Mercury Grand Marquee and that was with
the deluxe interiors and [__]
right then they would stretch them
slightly and make them look more like a
limousine under in the Lincoln line the
Lincoln Town Car and it had a bigger
motor I think it was like a five I think
it was a 5.4 L
V8 so the Lincoln Town Car was kind of
like the modern version of a bell area
it didn't look like what you're talking
about look more like a Crown Victoria
kind of rounded thing but it it had a
real nice interior it's all leather
[__] huge [__] air conditioner in
there you know because they were in the
South and it would be [__] Frosty
cold in those things well that's what
you want yeah and um I want ice on the
inside of the [__] yeah and of course uh
they had [__] ballistic packages in
other words [__] bullet resistant
packages you can get that that was for
VIP vehicles for like governors in case
you were at risk of being assassinated
yeah that was usually like Governors
because Governors used those like the
governor of Louisiana had one governor
of [__]
Mississippi Crown Victoria were in the
fleet in the state
Fleet and that's what they wrote around
in but uh that was kind of like Crown
Crown excuse me the uh Lincoln Town Car
the [__] high-end versions of them
were kind of like the best American
luxury car you could buy was that pretty
much from a major
manufacturer Town Car my only memory of
a Lincoln Town Car situation was when I
was a kid and one year I mean my family
we didn't have a lot of money so it's
like whenever we did a vacation which
was rarely we would just go to Disney
World because it was like an hour away
you know what I mean still expensive
though but you know what I mean
so one year we actually had some money
and we were going to Disney but my dad
actually rented a Lincoln Town Car yeah
and I think it was white and the inside
was like super plush and it was like
dark blue and everything like that I sat
in the backseat of that car I was a kid
and I was just like oh my God this must
be what it's like to be a rich person
yeah for like the hour drive like it was
it's like you're in a
room and when they're set up ni when
they're set up as a limo they can have a
partition between the the the people in
the back and then the people in the
front but even the basic
ones there's enough room in a Lincoln
Town Car to [__] you could [__] in a
Lincoln Town Car even a modern without
breaking stuff yeah yeah which I have SE
I have some experience with that LE they
had leather interiors really good sound
systems don't [__] a tiny Mazda
[__] they were real plush in there
they uh had a big [__] engine usually
it was the engine out of a van out of
like a Ford van or a
truck and they were wide they were I
think they were wider than a Crown
Victoria too most of these cars we're
talking about for our European listeners
were totally would be totally useless in
Europe especially in a city well they're
giant they're [__] giant they make
more sense in the United States you know
we have big open sprawling roads they're
nice for road trips man cuz you can just
like it's like woo you can free parking
everywhere and you know and there's
always empty parking spaces yeah but
yeah in Europe they're useless Europe be
useless you you wouldn't need that yeah
but the the sensation is is that you're
in a home and you're in a luxury home or
a luxury hotel room
driving and it's not about speed or
anything it's just about smooth ride and
luxury how you know [__] the sound
systems that's in there and and in in
the deluxe executive versions they're
actually armored they're bulletproofed
in certain areas armored glass armed do
I would think I you know what if I was
going to drive cross country which I
would like to do one day cuz it sounds
kind of fun um I would absolutely rent
Andor buy one of those really luxury
like Winnebago type situations I don't
want to drive it mind cuz those things
are [__] huge and I wouldn't be able
to park it but um cuz my my spatial
awareness is not great but I mean if
you're going to go whole hog and like
drive all the way across country like
for weeks and weeks and stuff like that
yeah you need like some luxury [__] like
that yeah matter of fact I had to look
into how much he used Lincoln Town Cars
cost we got to get link I know
everything about that system I know
everything about that those that kind of
car yeah because you can fix it I could
fix it you can fix it I can fix it I can
fix that I know everything about
chor lincol Grand Marque yeah Tom can
fix all of the all of those Amer
adjacent cars yeah cuz they're all very
simil reil those Motors before [__]
the Transmissions [__] I know
everything about the damn fuel injection
systems and the that's why we haven't
maybe that's why why we haven't spent
much money on my car because it's like
minor [__] like you can fix it yeah yeah
minor fix it you always just fix it but
if I could get if I could get my hands
on a decent [__] like say
2008 L uh Lincoln Town Car with a good
interior cuz a lot of them are ragged
out we'll be like the old school
retirees driving like a [__] riding
around in a [__]
limo I'll do it I don't care I don't
care how it look got to go to Ford and
see if they got a used one they're
trying to sell the thing is those by now
they all have 200,000 miles no problem
of course they do uh they can go 250
300,000 miles on the same on one engine
but it a lot of times it's time for a
new engine well the amazing thing about
my for Taurus is that even though it's
from 2004 it does not yet have 200,000
miles on it no yeah right it only has
what 160 170 whoever owned it before it
was a work vehicle so they didn't drive
it all that much when I was a kid if you
had 100,000 on your car it was a [__]
mess it was it was a wreck it was it was
dying that's not the way it really is
anymore no we're absolutely not um a
Crown Victoria can get 230,000 miles no
problem on on one engine I mean as long
as they're maintained yeah
right it's all the support stuff you
know what I mean you're going to need
[__]
alternators [__] fuel [__] pumps
uh [__] just little [__] like that
yeah the uh steer power steering pumps
[__] although I will say alternators
have always been my yeah alternators and
batteries it go out yeah well and the
thing about it is that battery is easier
because you just replace it every couple
years or whatever but alternator can go
out whenever without warning yeah I was
I had a Honda Civic and I was driving to
Miami actually which um from where I
lived at that point was a 5our drive and
uh my alternator just decided to goep
yeah and it just so I I didn't make it
to Miami that's all I'm saying when me
and Grands were kids back in the 80s you
could get you could get Lincoln Town
Cars from the 70s you could get them for
500 bucks That's how little people
wanted them they were like lots they
were eyes sore they were very large
[__] eyes sore they were very large
they looked terrible well they didn't
look look terrible look like a giant
hearse they were just they stuck out
like a sore thumb and it was a
definitely definitely it's an old man
car yeah and they [__] didn't have
there was no concept of fuel economy at
all it it' take you a gallon just to go
to Milk Man we don't even care gallon of
gas yeah it's like honestly if we got
one of those we should just like CSE it
out and then we should just like lean
into it man we'll just like be in there
like smoking big [__] cigars yeah put
some gray wigs on sh shooting shootting
porn in the back colored lights that we
have vampire that [__] out put a disco
ball in there well like I said maybe we
should look into that maybe we should
look into a car that's large enough for
us to shoot porn in the back seat that's
right then we can it can serve like you
know double Dual Purpose yeah we can
hire some of our friends to do porn in
the back have L you in a l cutting a
scene in the back me and Tony in the
front filming
it Tony directon yeah we'll see how that
goes but right
I mean you know it could be fun Macky ma
VR chat says happy holidays Tom and
Jenny thank you pooky and the two fur
babies I was almost thinking about
looking at Cadillacs Cadillacs used to
have [__] very low resale value
because it was an old man car and the
old man would die and then nobody wanted
to buy it when an old man wants a a
Cadillac he wants a new Cadillac he
doesn't want a used one he doesn't want
some dead dude's Cadillac it'll depress
him you know he used to be you could get
a cad plus it might be haunted yeah you
could get a used to be you could get a
Cadillac a dead dude's Cadillac [__]
cheap but I don't know what the what
this what what what it's like now I
think Cadillacs might have expensive
[__] upkeep I'm not sure I don't know
about yeah I haven't really kept up with
like all the newer car [__] so I don't
really know I used to K we're at the age
where we might even [__] want a
luxury
car pimp that [__]
up I mean you know drive it yeah but I
want some I want modern
I think I I think I want modern
electronic well like I said I like all
the good I like all the modern [__] on
and cars nowadays are like much safer
than they used to be back in the old
days so I like all the safety [__] I
like all the I like all the GPS I like
all the backup camera sh I like all all
that Bluetooth stuff yeah I like all
that so I don't want to go back to the
old days where it's like it didn't have
jack [__] on it the only modern car
that's impressed me recently for
practicality and just how it drove was
that Kia Soul that Korean car yeah I
never driven one of those it's fun to
drive you'd like it it's kind of like a
imagine that fit but a lot
shorter yeah the fit was kind of long
yeah the Honda Fit it looks kind of
small from the outside but it was
actually much larger inside than it
appeared this one's kind of like like a
you know imagine it shorter and more
square but tall yeah like a van like a
little small
van what money what do you say who is
that thank you Zach Jack okay sent Tom
some picks of the Holden Effigy an
Aussie concept car would love to know
what y'all think it's so gorgeous he
sent me pictures of it yeah he sent you
pictures of it so you better check for
that I know I got so behind sorry all
right genx Jason said Tom if you buy a
Town Car get a 2005 or newer the older
ones have plastic intake that breaks and
is a [__] to change okay he that's good
to know yeah so 20 well yeah we would
defin because my car my Ford Taurus that
we have is a 2004 so I definitely want
something that's like um at least a
decade newer than that no that car is
[__] sweet
man that is yeah yeah that is [__]
sweet that is cool looking yeah me and
Jen would love some [__] like that that
is cool looking that almost looks like a
cartoon car which I'm into that what do
you call that it's a well wait a minute
move the move the [__] so I can see um a
Holden Effigy yeah how much do they want
it's Australian it's a concept car okay
yeah so concept
car so that is nice though I I think
that's really cool
looking yeah style look like the 50s
yeah it looks like an old gangster car
that's super
cool um Oracle said the PT Cruiser
didn't have enough headro yeah I never
sat in one so they looked like they had
enough Headroom but like I said I guess
they didn't
because I don't I don't know man like
cars can be deceptive because I think a
lot of people I had a Honda Fit and I
bought it new in 2013 I sold it later
but um and a lot of people was like oh
my God like how can you even sit in that
thing it's so tiny but it was actually
really big on the inside it was very C
forward yeah it didn't really look like
it that it would be but it was like
really big on the
inside or says we love our K Soul oh
yeah oh okay so she's got one yeah okay
yeah we that's one of the ones that we
were thinking about getting yeah I drove
one one of the early ones and I liked it
it was just a a Nimble practical little
car good M had good gas mileage on it it
had a good back seat for passengers and
it had a decent trunk it had a like a a
fat like a lift back would be a good
kind of like a van in the back right I
liked
it Danny ask what's Tom and Jenny's
dream car mine is the 93 Toyota MR2 oops
where did it go
uh it
moved now I can't see
it maybe he deleted it but I was reading
it and it went away yeah so [__] who
said that uh that was Danny yeah yeah he
deletes his comments for some well I I
think they just delete like
automatically zanada also says my 2002
Toyota Tacoma so you got one that's
older than me okay has only 186,000
miles and it's never had a problem yeah
one thing about Toyotas they always
start even in 30° yeah I've had a couple
of Toyotas and they were also very
relaxed I had a to when I was a kid my
dad gave me a Toyota Corolla SR5 it was
a 1983 or four I don't remember and that
was one of the best [__] cars I've
ever owned it was a [__] it was a
Fastback too Fastback [__] manual
transmission and it was like a little
[__] hot rod had a good time with it
never had any problems just changed the
[__] brake
pads Corolla [__]
SR5 badass car great mileage even in the
80s it was getting great
mileage yeah I had a couple of Toyotas I
had a Honda um I had a Nissan so I've
had mostly Japanese cars you looked at
it just looked like a Volkswagen Rabbit
or something but it had like a little
sporty feel to it you know you could
[__] wrap a [__] out of that little
engine was light good stereo for the
time uh mackim Mack also said the one
who said happy holidays and said happy
holidays to Pooky and the other two cats
the other two kitties names are Bambi
and be Beijing Beijing yeah Bambi is our
newest acquisition we just got her a few
months ago she's still she starting to
settle in she's kind of starting to
settle in yeah she's also kind of crazy
but all of our cats are weird but like
in different ways yeah her when we got
her her name was Dakota that's what they
named her at the shelter but we called
her Bambi cuz she looks like a baby deer
kind of yeah um but yeah she's she's
mental but I I love her she's awesome um
but yeah he also said I want to see a
goth styled Christmas
decor you know what we haven't like the
tree is up it's called crampus yeah the
tree is up yeah but that's about it we
haven't even put out I didn't put my
projector we this is how sad we are
we've only put up we only have like the
Christmas projectors that so we have a
snow is it snowflakes yeah snowflakes
snowfl and I think Santa faces right
yeah Santa faces Santa faces so we have
like two of the Prett because we like
like the laziest yeah we're lazy but you
know even for like the Halloween decor
one of these days I'd like to get like a
whole like [__] Halloween thing going
out there cuz Halloween's my that's my
holiday I like Christmas too but you
know what I mean but even for Halloween
we only have like the projectors we got
bats and ghosts I think but yeah for
Christmas oh no wait a minute maybe it's
not Santa faces isn't it pepper is it
peppermint things I don't remember it's
been a long time I don't I can't
remember either care but we haven't even
put those out but we we do have we do we
do have the tree up though we do have
the tree up though but it's just like
regular looking it's just regular
looking we had to get a bigger tree when
we moved here because the ceiling no get
a smaller tree downstairs or smaller
tree rather because the ceiling is like
I don't know the way ceiling big the
other ceiling it's not as big as the
other ceiling so we had to get like a
smaller one it wasn't the tree we had
before was too tall you know what I mean
so
yeah all right so everybody's talking
about Camp guy said this is so funny I
think I pitched a woo oh my God I
haven't heard I haven't heard that
phrase in a l that's like a very very
old timey um phrase for sex okay pitch
to woo in the backseat of a 78 79 or
1980 Oldsmobile Delta 88 back in the day
oh my God my brother had an Oldsmobile
Delta 88 it was white I remember that we
went to so many shows in that [__]
car that was back in the what man that
that must have been back in the 80s
oldmobile is gone now isn't it wait do
they still have oldmobile I think it's
gone I don't remember a lot of the
American companies are
gone oldmobile I don't think could keep
up with anything they couldn't keep up
with any of the trans right there in the
name old yeah it was I mean they had a
problem keeping up with Chrysler you
know which is also kind of an old yeah
right yeah like I said my dad had
Chryslers for a long time Chryslers are
well they're not what they used to be
well no but like yeah that like I said
this is back in like the 90s or
something yeah but I remember in the 80s
my brother had an oldmobile I'm not sure
Chrysler's around
anymore yeah I'm not real sure like I
said I I haven't kept up I haven't kept
up Chrysler Buick those were the ones
that were always kind of
lagging especially in the 80s well like
I said and it's and I feel like most
people have the perception that those
are like old people cars yeah and I
guess that's true because you know it's
not like young people are like clamoring
to buy those no they couldn't come up
with any designs to attract young
people Santa said my brother has an old
70s Volkswagen Rabbit I loved that car
yeah they're well made simple
I kind of feel like I do like all the
bells and whistles like all the
technological [__] they have on cars
nowadays but there is something to be
said
for stuff that doesn't have a lot of
things on it yeah because it's fewer
things to break yeah not necessarily
true with cars but I think that's kind
of true of like but particularly like a
lot of appliances and stuff like that
because you know how they had like they
have the new refrigerators and [__] like
that that it's like oh it has Ai and
it'll tell you when you're out of stuff
like without even opening the door and
like that you have to it's like look I
don't need that I can just open the door
and see that we're out of milk or
whatever and go to the store I don't
really need I I to me that's just one
more thing to break the rabbit the
rabbit was the uh updated version of the
beetle it's it had engine in the front
instead of the back you know what I
mean I don't think it was front-wheel
drive I think it was rear wheel drive if
I remember which made everything a lot
made everything a lot more
simple it had actual air conditioning in
it an actual [__] uh cuz a lot of
stuff a lot of stuff in the Volkswagen
Bug I had a Volkswagen Bug when I was in
Brazil and it was new not an old one a
new one they still make them in South
America or at least they did when I was
kid and uh a lot of the [__] in there in
a Volkswagen Bug was a real half
ass the drivetrain and the body were
solid um the motor was [__] rock
solid it didn't produce any power so it
would never really wear itself out it
just run
forever as long as there was some kind
of oil in it you were good to
go and the one I had was uh adapted for
alcohol burning because in Brazil we use
something called [__] alol which is
[__] sugar cane
alcohol and it would just put putt
around it didn't you know it didn't have
any
needs but when it came to
heater heat was real spotted
there was no air conditioning at all I
think some of the models had them but it
probably didn't work well and it was
probably a separate system was probably
something
that required gas or electric to run the
air conditioning I'm think I think in
the folks wagon beetle if I remember
correctly that air conditioning was not
a practical
option
um when the rabbit came out it kind of
was like that was more of a conventional
modern car liid liquid cooling instead
of air cooling engine was in the front I
think it was a live axle in the back uh
real AC real heater better
interior uh sound
system um Power no they didn't have
power steering they had regular [__]
mechanical steering I think most of them
but it was they were Rock Solid it was
really nothing that could break in a
Volkswagen Rabbit they were they were
move up from a from a bug they had those
in Brazil also that was like the the uh
the second most popular car first most
popular car when I was there was
Volkswagen
Bug they called it a fusa which is the
Portuguese slang word for bug or
roach roach fusa they look more I always
pictur them more like a ladybug than a
roach yeah well Brazilians just called a
fusa bug but they're usually referring
to a roach
yeah Oracle said we had a cat named
clout house by the shelter because he
was found in an alley during Christmas
we called him dartanion or Dart for
short yeah she doesn't I don't know why
they named her Dakota specifically um
that was her name when she came from the
shelter and then she was transported to
PetSmart uh where we found her actually
on the day that she came to PetSmart uh
we went in there and happened to look at
the cats and we were looking for a
another cat and she was a MX and we were
like oh my goodness and she looked
really cute so we adopted her but for so
we called her Dakota for a while but
then I kept noticing her movements and
the way cuz she's also a Max her tail is
longer than pookies like pookies is just
like about as long as your thumb but
Dakota's SL bambies is about that long
yeah and so from the back like her
coloring and stuff she kind of looks
like it looks like a deer tail like look
like a white tail deer and also she's
kind of like floppy yeah like the way
Bambi was when he was first born like
you know what I mean like with the long
legs and everything so I just St Conor
Bambi or Bam Bam zanada said that the uh
the golf replaced the rabbit yeah but I
also think that the rabbit and the golf
used a lot of the same components I
think the I think if I remember
correctly it's been a long time since
I've seen those cars I think the golf
was a rabbit an improved rabbit well I
thought the golf was what they called
like the rabbit in EUR in Europe might
have been I thought yeah I could be
wrong about that though yeah the r they
call they called him the golf in Brazil
but we called it a rabbit because a lot
of people had VW golfs in Europe when
there I think he might be on to
something though I think the original
was the rabbit and I think it got
upgraded into the golf but I think maybe
the golf might have might have had some
differences but I'm not sure um they
were good
cars the Toyota Corolla SR5 was the
Japanese version of the Volkswagen Golf
that's what they were that's what they
were trying to put a spin on and Toyota
did it a lot better A lot better
faster more more uh high teack for the
time um better
transmission better reliability better
AC better [__] uh uh heat climate
control in the
inside they had fastbacks and hatchbacks
different versions of
them I like the that that old [__]
Corolla they never had a problem with it
they just phased it out because they
wanted something more expensive the
Corollas ended up being a high-end car
you couldn't get them cheap you could
get them cheap when I was a kid though
in the mid
80s that was just like an economy car
Camp guy said my old man always wanted a
Cadillac don't they all um he ended up
getting a Lincoln Town Car when he was
about 68 or 70 years old then he died
about five or six years later from uh
metastatic gastric cancer we finally
ended up selling that car for about 2400
bucks whoever bought it got a good deal
yeah I guess so I remember that I was
well that's kind of why when I was in
high school that's how you got them
right you would kind of like look at the
obituary yeah look at the you'd find
some old man's [__] Cadillac or
Lincoln Town Car for sale you could get
it for a song but the thing is is that
you're a teenage kid trying to buy this
[__] thing old old people wouldn't
buy them because they wanted a new one
yeah and [__] working people didn't
want that they didn't want to commute in
that piece of [__] they're [__] hu
too huge man the amount of money so then
you ended up you're a teenager with this
old man's [__] land yacht all right
and you can barely afford to keep gas in
it but like I said on the plus side you
could [__] it you could [__] it it
was a mobile Hotel you could take it to
the drivein and you and your girl be in
there bouncing that thing up and down on
the [__] park behind a church like
out in the park or something like that
but heaven forbid anything went wrong
with it cuz you couldn't afford to fix
it yeah that was the Dum yeah that was
the go to restroom
uh yeah timobile is done says Titanic
discussions also Danny says Chrysler is
around Plymouth isn't Plymouth yeah I
always forget about Plymouth and Pontiac
is also gone yeah Plymouth and Pontiac I
always forget about Plymouth that's like
the [__] red redheaded step child of
redheaded step children the only reason
I know about Plymouth is because of
Christine yeah Plymouth cuz she was a
Plymouth was she
not yeah I thought she was that's really
I haven't seen them in a very long
time Macky Max said Tom and Jenny should
do a photo shoot Gothic version of St
Nick and Mrs Claus maybe we should I
don't have any Christmas outfits though
unfortunately I don't know maybe I could
put something
together we never do like we always mean
to do all this stuff around Christmas
time and we just like we never do you
know what I mean I don't know it's just
because we're lazy or we don't have the
[__] or I don't know what it is um Dana
said Toyota heaters work great my old
Toyota still has great heat yeah
um I don't know I wouldn't know about
that because it's like I've never turned
the heat around in my car
ever I've never needed
to you know even a couple times like
we've been out and it's been kind of
cold at night times like I don't put the
heat on I'm like no you were not going
to put the [__] heat on I don't like
the heat on I don't like the heat on in
the house I would rather be cold with a
[__] blanket I don't I don't like the
heat on it's [__] Florida we don't
need to turn the [__] heat on it's
not that cold put a blanket on and quit
crying um yeah Dana also says I prefer
Lincoln over Cadillac personally yeah I
don't really have enough I mean when I
think about Cadillac I always just think
about my grandpa because my
grandpa who died a long time ago um he
was a hoarder and one of the things he
hoarded was cars and boats so he had a
[__] ton of Cadillacs like parked in the
backyard of his his house in Daytona
Beach South Daytona actually it was but
he just loved Cadillacs and he had a
bunch of them I Learned to Drive in one
of them actually it was [__] gigantic
like I said it was just like it's like a
big [__]
boat but man when I was a kid I didn't
really think about it when I was a kid
because I was a kid you know what I mean
but we spent a lot of time to his house
we even lived there a few times you know
when money was tight or whatever and and
my
grandfather um after my grandmother
divorced him
in sometime in the 70s I want to say so
it's mid to late 70s or the 80s maybe um
cuz before that like the house had been
cuz it was a nice house it was big it
was like twostory and all this other
stuff and she kept that [__] like
Immaculate but as soon as she left yeah
it all went to [__] and there was
basically like one
path through the downstairs and there
was just crap on all the way sides of it
you know what I mean um and his backyard
was kind of the same like he loved boats
he loved he was like real
into cameras jewelry guns like all that
kind of stuff so his whole house was
just like full of stuff like that like
he would go to estate sales and buy all
of that stuff so whenever so I'm kind of
fascinated I will sit there and watch
hours and hours of that show Hoarders
because I can relate my grandfather was
just like that and especially like a lot
of the male hoarders I like that the
newer episodes or the newer seasons of
Hoarders I've noticed they have started
putting more men on there because as far
as I know hoarding is actually more
common in men but for a long time the
hoarder show it seemed like it was all
women and I felt like maybe that was
either because women were more willing
to go on the show like dudes were too
embarrassed or something like that but
now it's kind of like 50/50 and every
time you see the dudes on Hoarders they
always say they're exactly the same as
my grandfather was it's like they pick
up [__] like from dumpsters and like on
the side of I can use this they never do
though they see value in everything they
see use in everything you know what I
mean I'm goingon to I'm going to you
know pick up this thing like from the
side of the road and I'm going to fix it
and I'm going to sell it and so but they
never do but they never do you know
what's funny I'm talking about Plymouth
I always try to remember Plymouth I was
think man there was another car made
I forgot what his name was but it's gone
now but that the [__] used to be big but
it's gone I can't remember the name
Plymouth yeah like the Plymouth Fury
yeah it was oh that's what the car was
that was Christine Plymouth Fury that's
right I knew it was a Plymouth what's
weird about that [__] is that that was a
very Noble brand back in its day they
built some [__] really cool [__]
cars in the 40s and 50s you know I think
they had some of the 30s too 50s and
60s and it just kind of faded it away is
a [__] real mundane fart [__] car
I mean it's all they were very mundane
when they
died and may me think that you know they
got dead Mall videos we had to do dead
car videos we do a whole video about how
[__] how
cool that car brand was and then what it
ended up as over time because like well
nothing is like eternally nothing's
Eternal yeah no and I can't s think of a
single by the time the 80s and rolled
around Plymouth was making some of the
[__] most boring [__] square boxy
cars that you could imagine and uh not
good
quality but in the 50s man during their
Heyday it was [__] Chrome beautiful
colors and huge and it's like something
mam somebody in the 50s would [__]
sell their left net
for well I mean when I saw the movie of
Christine in
1983 um that Plymouth Fury in that movie
is [__] awesome looking and I would
happily own that car yeah I don't even
think that was one of their better ones
it was just like a good one yeah you
know I mean the one they had for the
movie was [__] cool looking as what
I'm saying I don't know if I wouldn't
have it because it would be too
expensive like main it but it's [__]
cool looking I think Plymouth had ones
that they considered to be even better
than the
fury
for its day you
know and I thought maybe I thought I
remember reading that the cars they used
in the movie weren't actually Furies but
I could be wrong about that because they
had more than one obviously because they
had a trash a bunch of them Zan said
tell Tom I want to send you guys the
original Cocaine Cowboys movie made by
Billy Corbin okay but it's not in
Blu-ray He's only seen the Netflix
series the original movie is a lot
better you can send you can send me on
DVD yeah we we can play DVD if it's not
available on Blue Blu-ray set DVD yeah
yeah it said it's about the 1980s Miami
drug war yeah we loved that series to be
honest yeah we'll do we'll do a show on
it yeah yeah we totally should yeah oh
and I think we're going to do for the
movie review that we do on Monday I
think we're going to do um the man who
killed Hitler and then the B Bigfoot
okay because um somebody asked us about
it and Sam Elliot I heard of it and it's
and it's on 2B for free I checked so
it's like yeah I been wanting to see
that anyway guess what people I knew you
were going to bring this up at you know
just what I'm talking about I know
exactly see I can read your mind she's
reading my mind
already Beverly Hills Cop 4 the the
trailer got dropped it's coming out on
[__]
Netflix next summer next summer and the
[__] it looks good the trailer looks
very good it's got the all original cast
it's got tager It's got Rosewood in it
it's got the old police chief you know
what's crazy I thought John Ashton was
dead they're in there I just did a movie
review a couple weeks ago about a movie
that he was in back in 2016 2017 called
Uncle John and I thought that he had
died not long after making that but
obviously he's still alive because Serge
is in it yeah it looks like Bronson
pincho was in there yeah Serge is in it
and [__] then uh get the [__] out of
here yeah he's back in and what I like
about it is that it it looks like it has
an edge it looks like a modern movie it
does look fun and it it looks fun and
[__] Murphy man that [__] doesn't
age much does he I know I was reading an
article about that earlier because a lot
of people are talking about the trailer
and it's like is this are they using
daging on him or something it's like he
doesn't look any different than he did
in the [__] 80s like he looks pretty
much well he's got a little more mass to
him he's thicker yeah he's thicker but
it's like other than that he doesn't
look like an old man and he's what
62 63 older than me by far he's in his
60s yeah he's probably on HRT and just
keeping himself he looks great yeah just
keeping himself you know I mean he looks
very young still yeah and he looks
energetic man like high testosterone
that's good yeah he might be on a bunch
of stuff well I mean he's got the money
he's probably on test you know I mean
and just going to the
gym I love I loved Axel Foley I love
that character I [__] I even had a
soft spot for [__] part three a lot
of people hate part three though yeah I
kind of have soft spot there's certain
parts there's certain things about part
three that I liked execution of part
three was very blocky it was kind of had
a cheap feeling to it it was a cash grab
for sure yeah like a cash grab and but
this one I got a [__] feeling that
this is going to wash away that damn bad
taste that part three left in a lot of
people's mouth but I think this is going
to be good if if it's [__] as good as
it if it's as good as [__] um
Dolomite yeah Dolomite was [__]
that's kind of what I was thinking I was
like man if this is as good as Dolomite
then that's going got Dolomite on
Blu-ray yeah just classic gonna say I
didn't love the Coming to America sequel
it was okay it was pretty good it was
pretty good it was okay it could have
been better though but Dolomite I
[__] loved we've seen that like two
or three times at this point yeah
Dolomite that's that's classic flick
love so if it's as good as that then
I'll be happy I'm just kind of pissed
off that they're not having a theatrical
release I'd go to theater to see that I
want to see that in the theater I know
they really should have I mean they
could do it I don't know Netflix doesn't
usually do that though do they they
don't they don't do like some of the
other streaming services will do like a
simultaneous simult yeah you know or
they'll or like what they'll do a lot of
times is they'll it'll be in the theater
for a couple weeks and then like the
streaming service will get it you know
what I mean they even got the [__]
thing they got yeah F FAL that's what
his name is I think it's going to be
good pull that out my I got I'm hoping
the Traer looks good the trailer looks
good trailer looks good the trailer
looks good I'm I'm just kind of hoping
it won't be good I don't I think I think
Eddie Murphy produced it he co-produces
it
Eddie's made a strong comeback with
Dolomite and it was pretty good the only
Pro the problem with Coming to America
was that three come coming to America
Two was was it two or three yeah was it
two or now I can't remember I think it
was two I think it was two yeah it was
PG yeah
I yeah they should have like pushed it
harder right it would have been better
so but really uh since Eddie made his
comeback uh [__] I've been satisfied
and I've been a I've been an Eddie
Murphy fan since I was a little kid all
right I mean he's a funny [__]
since when I was a little kid and I'm
not supposed to be seeing him on [__]
Saturday Night Live I'm too young you
[__] and then uh [__]
um 48 Hours one and
two then Beverly Hills Cop he [__]
blew it out of the water in one and two
two I think Beverly Hills Cop two is a
masterpiece I I like both of them yeah a
lot of people like the first two but
like I said most people really do not
like the third one which I don't even
remember that much about honest with you
and those movies kind of spoke to me
because you know I did time in Detroit
and that's where Axel was from you know
like in the Michigan area me me and
[__] Grand so I kind of knew the
culture where they're trying to come
from with that and then they're showing
the fish out of the water element where
he's from a place like Detroit hanging
out in Beverly Hills this [__] which
that still plays I mean even in the
modern era still do something with that
huge difference cuz it hasn't changed
that much since the80s I feel like yeah
but um me and Mike Kowalski friend of
mine and [__] Steve Rouse and [__]
[__] Axel Foley was a hero of ours
man that was a that was a [__] great
character who's a cop who he's a good
dude he started off as a
criminal you know uh but he chased his
ways and he did his thing and and and
he's funny and he's doing [__] that
would would never happen in real life
but that's okay it's a movie but it's
just the movie you know it was 80s
action flip it's just fun yeah 80s fun
action flick he's [__] 24 and he's
kind of [__] around with senior cops
in their 50s they would have set his ass
right okay [__] but it was just good
it was good I think it was like a it was
kind of a buddy flick it was up there
with [__] Lethal Weapon one and two
and I like to Lethal Weapon series to
yeah well the first two at least yeah
one and two was the best one the other
one it's got kind of it started going on
a along well that that happens with
pretty much every happens movie but I
have all the lethal weapons movies I
bought them all in a
package the storytelling is pretty good
because it's it's Buddy stories it's a
story about it's male friendship yeah
stories and those are always fun
everybody likes those yeah and even even
[__] the Joe Pet's gangster character
was kind of like ended up accepted as
one of the guys with these cops he
wasn't a cop but they were they were
friends with him so it was just it was
just
a a Feelgood story arc they buddy movies
yeah which you don't see anymore but I
think I think well no I think they still
make them it's just that they're not big
bud yeah there's so many movies nowadays
it's like hard to they get lost in the
show closest thing to the big to Buddy
movies nowadays would probably be
something from Fast and Furious series
yeah like
the the what something in Hobbs was
pretty good wasn't in that movie we saw
that one in the theater I would say
Calvin and Hobs no that's yeah that was
kind of like a buddy
movie yeah what are their names
something in Hobs [__] man we saw that
in the theater didn't we yeah I liked it
I did too but I don't remember anything
about I don't remember anything about it
but I remember it was fun at the
time I don't know [__] now I can't I
don't know if those movies I don't I
have that's I think that might have been
the only Fast and Furious movie I think
I saw the first first one but I don't
remember cuz I where I used to work I
used to work at a newspaper in Daytona
and there was a guy that worked there
and he loved movies and he would kind of
like he um pirated every movie ever yeah
um and he would loan them to me he's
like hey you want to see this and I'm
just like sure why not so he would like
just loan me this like [__] random
ass blank CD that had a movie on it so a
lot of times I'd put him on now
sometimes I wouldn't sit and watch him
I'd be just like doing laundry or doing
housework or something like that like
while it was on so I didn't sit and
watch it but so I've seen a lot of
movies that I maybe wouldn't have
watched otherwise because that's not
like my genre you know what I mean he
was real into like big budget like
action kind of movies so I saw a lot of
those even though because I was like hey
it's free you know Eddie Eddie Murphy's
problem was when he started to have his
own production his own Studios and he
tried to go familyfriendly so he's
basically trying to fill Bill Cosby's
[__] shoes Hobs and Shaw that was the
name of that Hobs and Shaw I knew one of
yall would remember actually want buy
like H all I can think of was Calvin and
H yeah I actually want I actually want
to buy Hobs com I liked it um it was
pretty I remember I remember liking I
don't remember anything about it but I
remember it being fun what went wrong
with Eddie Murphy is that he tried to go
mainstream he tried to go
familyfriendly never done don't do that
don't do that his best movies
were 48 Hours bever the Hills Cop
Trading Places was great I [__]
trying to find I really like I like
trading can't find a Blu-ray version of
it I like Trading Places uh maybe they
have it now but it was a while a few
years back I was looking for it I want
to see Trading Places again
um uh [__] I I I'm a big fan of the
golden sh I couldn't find that I kind of
have a soft spot for that too I don't
like it as much as I liked it back in
the 80s when I first saw it um cuz when
we rewatched it again a couple years ago
I was like I don't like that as much as
I used to you forgot how much of a be
movie that was yeah I did that's what it
is those were be movies but I still have
a soft spot for it they were very good
it's so weird weird like what a weird
concept yeah I got the knife I love how
ballsy that concept was I was like no
one would do that nowaday cuz it's just
like bizarre he had the little kid
[__] he must he must have get the
Shante dagger the they're fighting the
devil and [__] through this this little
buddha yeah I saw that movie like a
million times on cable back in the old
days
yeah but uh [__] the thing is I don't
think there was a Blu-ray release I have
I have a DVD release I think I got to go
back and look yeah I don't know if
theyve uh be I remember I remember
thinking that it needed to be remastered
and it needed to be like [__]
remastered as a blue release those were
[__] B movies bever the hill cop was
a b movie yeah when you see it it's
rough it didn't matter though that
[__] movie has soul and it was so
[__] funny it's hilarious
and it still holds up I think it still
holds up it started to go lame his
problems and and here's another one that
I [__] liked Vampire in Brooklyn I
think that was his last good movie from
that era and a lot of people don't like
that mov I like it though I still have a
soft spot for I thought it was a strong
vampire movie strong vampire you I can
see why people don't like it but I kind
of like it he's doing a he's doing a
play on blackula yeah and [__] I
liked
it um but then it started to go into
[__]
uh Nutty Professor type [__] and what
was the name what was the uh the guy he
did he did Haunted Mansion man Dr D
little yeah and he started doing stuff
like it's like oh I'm going to be in a
fat suit I'm like Christmas with the
cranks or whatever was that Eddie Murphy
yeah I don't know so he's doing some
stuff it was almost like Proto who's
that [__] that does all those
movies nowadays like the media movie
media yeah which some of those are good
like what's that dude's name I forgot
his name but I like someone de I'll
think of it in a second but like that it
was almost like Proto that dude
um yeah so God what's his name it's
right on the tip of my tongue well
actually that guy was ripping off Eddie
Murphy well yeah that's what I'm saying
so that's what I'm saying Eddie Murphy
was like a Proto that guy um so so I
don't love that anytime you're kind of
gonna if your whole thing is edgy comedy
it better stay on there then you got to
stay on top of your Edge if you're going
to go into familyfriendly
stuff
it didn't work for him I don't love it
well I mean I don't love familyfriendly
like look I love animated movies as much
as the next person but I don't like
anything that's just kind of like very
specifically geared toward yeah we're
going to make something like for kids
you know what I mean right Murphy un
unless it's got some kind of creativity
or some kind of edge to it Murphy's
thing I was K I was a kid I was there
when it was happening his thing was that
was funny and edgy Tyler Perry thank
Tyler Perry yeah he's an Eddie Murphy
ripoff even though know I respect his
work he's good uh Tom loved that media
funeral that we went to the theater saw
in the theater I was laughing through
the whole [__] I was like I did I hated
it kind of well I didn't hate it but I
was like man this is dumb as [__] but I
was Tom's gonna love this though love
this I knew you were gonna love it when
I was watching it I said Tom's gonna
love this [__] when Murphy came back
with Dolomite I knew he was back God
damn that movie was so good okay if you
haven't seen Dolomite as my name please
see that so so good and it's a true
story he's PL it's a true story it's
like well it kind of reminded me like
the vibe of it was like Ed Wood yeah
like Ed Wood because it was like it was
about Rudy Raymore who was who made
terrible movies but they were fun but
they were still funny if like
unintentionally uh a lot of times but
the spirit behind it it's like look we
are not talented at all
but I'm going to disagree they were
talented no they were but I'm just
saying that like you know they didn't
have you know they didn't have a lot of
the talent that may be bigger you know
what I mean but was like but they had
have the money to make right and they
didn't have the money or anything like
that but they just like really wanted to
make the movies man and they just like
it was like really inspirational right
well the reason the reason why Murphy
was such an end for that is cuz he knew
more he was friends with him and really
what Murphy was doing in his early film
career that made him famous was the same
thing that Rudy Ray Moore was doing he
had more money than Rudy Ray and he was
more and arguably more talented than
Rudy Raymore I ain't gonna [__] with
Rudy Ray like that Rudy Ray was talented
within the framework of his time and
what he had like in an Edwood type of
situation right which Edwood was
objectively a terrible filmmaker however
it was entertaining his movies are still
entertaining so I would argue that he
might be talented that that he's kind of
talented just unintentionally which that
works too that works
too you know Ruby Ray was making black
product yeah he was making stuff that
black people wanted to see and it worked
they came and saw it and it was and it
was uh underground you know he would
have a release in the theater you had to
buy tickets at I love PD weat straw the
devil son-in-law the devil son-in-law
it's devil son-in-law right I think it's
Dev devil son-in-law which I think is on
tub or it was a couple months ago yeah
super fun he's he does all kinds of [__]
some's he's a secret agent pimp mhm
that's that's know he's all kinds of
[__] it's funny man and he knows Kung Fu
kind of knows Kung Fu kind of fix it
yeah
yeah but it's uh it's it's like grind
house yeah you know what I mean you're
just making a movie so yeah I thought it
was good but see that's what's cool
about that kind ofite my name is a movie
with Eddie Murphy telling the story of
Rudy Raymore right and it's like I said
it's super inspiration
because like people had it's like
watching Edwood yeah it's like people
that had no money and arguably little
Talent um but they were godamn it they
were G to make a [__] movie yeah and
they were all in yeah Wesley Snipes is
in it yeah yeah it's so good yeah it's
so good which is Snipes is another one
that [__] was uh very talented and um
he got in trouble with the IRS and
[__] kind of you didn't see him much
but he he's back
do you know what movie you need to see
that you probably
haven't is to Wong Fu Thanks for
Everything Julie numar I don't know
which has Wesley Snipes yeah uh Patrick
suy okay and who else was in that Jen Lu
John leguisamo okay in drag as drag
queens yeah right it is wildly
entertaining not as good as not quite as
good as um Priscilla Queen of the Desert
yeah which is a similar theme
um but still very entertaining you might
like it actually my favorite Wesley SN
movie is Demolition Man with Sylvester
Stallone it's a futuristic movie it's
it's it's the it's a documentary it's
all true it's a [__] great movie uh
if you guys haven't seen it uh Sandra
Bullock's in it and it's kind of like an
Arnold Schwarz ner movie Sandra bulock
always kind of pissed me off for some
reason I'm not really sure I'm not
really sure I know a lot of people do
yeah but I don't know there was just
something about that always rub me the
wrong way and I can't really put my
finger on what it is she was just some
cute upbeat chick I don't know there's
something about her that always like
really annoyed me and I don't know what
it is which kind of bothers me but I
can't really I can't like I said I can't
put my finger out I know a lot of people
don't and it's like so I don't know it's
she just kind of a generic something
that's wrong with me I guess kind of
like a generic American chick but it's
like something about her just always
like rub me the wrong way like whenever
I would see her in a movie I'm like man
[__] off I like bu you know mean she's
kind of just a good girl kind of a good
maybe that's why I didn't like her
Oracle said stalker Channing is in two
Wong Fu too that's right I forgot about
that good old Rizzo I love stalker
Channing she's
awesome uh wild and wonderful Whitney
said I love that movie not sure which
one we're talking about but yeah maybe
it's to Wong Fu but yeah I kind of feel
I've been wanting to like make Tom watch
I don't I don't actually think he's seen
prilly Queen of the Desert either even
though that's one of my favorite movies
ever but um I mean you know the two the
they're not the same but they're kind of
similar like the theme of them so I
should show them those we'll do like a
drag queen we'll do a drag queen double
feature one of these days it'll be
Priscilla Queen of the Desert and tuang
Fu that'll be like really cool I
think yeah Ian England [__]
Demolition Man Is Awesome three
seashells yeah Ian England said I'm with
you Jenny she just seems too preppy
maybe that's what it is maybe she just
seemed like too Normy for me um I okay I
think what it is maybe this is what it
is I think that the way that she was
marketed and I don't I don't know if
this was entirely her fault probably not
but the way she's marketed is just kind
of like she's this
obviously beautiful hot chick but every
movie that she was in there was always
something quote unquote like wrong with
her like she was always oh she's super
clumsy or she's like they always kind of
like have to give like the hot girl like
some kind of like Quirk and she seems
like the embodiment of that really
annoying Hollywood Trope you know what I
mean where it's like here's yeah like
here's this super hot girl obviously and
we're going to put her in this movie but
we have to give her this like
funny like
shortfall um usually with Sandra Bullock
it would usually be like she was super
clumsy or super awkward or something
like that she's kind she's kind of like
a character actress actually yeah and
it's like and clearly she's probably not
like that in real life and it's like I
don't know why that just kind of got on
my nerves like the way that I so I don't
know if it's so much her that's pissing
me off or the way that she's portrayed
that was pissing me off proba the
writing that's yeah I think that's what
it like I said so I'm not blaming her
I'm sure that wasn't like her fault
entirely because that's what she got
cast into yeah I also never really saw
her as hot saw her as cute yeah she's
not yeah there cuz there's kind of a
yeah she wasn't really she wasn't really
hot cute sexy those are different terms
yeah yeah cute and funny yeah she's
pretty although I never thought I never
found her particularly funny though
either no she had a lot of she had a lot
of good lines in uh in demolition Ma you
know come on let's go blow this guy he
goes no blow this guy away that's
remember that [__] you it yeah I haven't
seen that while she just said all kind
yeah she said a lot of [__] it was F
funny she was a student of 80s culture
right remember that and she she
misunderstood a lot of a lot of the the
culture of the time and she she' try to
use uh swear words and expressions that
she heard from history lessons I think
yeah because the original material
wasn't wasn't available in her time
right so when they were G to catch the
bad guy come on let's go blow this guy
and [__] right so it's kind of that
is very that is very style humor it's
let's blow this guy away where it's just
kind of like where where a lot of the
humor comes from like misunderstanding
or like somebody being a dummy right
yeah you know what I mean yeah so Ian
England agrees with me so I'm glad I'm
not the only person yeah said she was
just seemed too pre preppy and said
she's pretty but I've always found her
insufferable yeah me too and I'm like I
said it's no no ding on her I'm sure
she's a lovely person but it's just kind
of like I don't know something about her
has always pissed me off the way she was
cast maybe that's what it was yeah cuz
she always did kind of get cast in those
kind of roles but those were those were
roles of the time yeah of the times
there was that was that type that
character type which maybe I just don't
like that character type so the fact
that she was always kind of cast in
those roles she always cast like the
chick that [__] wasn't prepared for
this [__] she's thrust into this
situation and she's just trying to you
know what I mean and she's just trying
to cish she's like oh my God I'm so
[__] you know what I mean yeah so I
was just kind I don't know last long
that was '90s yeah that was the very 9s
I mean there was a lot of that going on
in the ' 80s too but I kind of like I
don't really I don't know so I just
didn't really like that Trope I guess so
maybe that's what it was cuz I kind I
associate her with that troop and I
don't like that troop so maybe that's
what it is I don't know I don't think
she was anything like that she was going
out with Jess probably not she was
dating Jessie James yeah she's probably
a lot cooler in person hang out bikers
and [__] but I don't know I don't know
her in person although he dumped her he
said she was [__] sufferable he got
sick of her oh well so
maybe so maybe I'm right about it maybe
is annoying in real life I don't really
know I don't I don't know her I can't
say that I remember it's been a long
time since
I've thought about that or [__] I had
to go back and investigate remember when
it went went down I think uh I think
other women may have been involved I
think Jesse Jesse James dumped her for
somebody
else well that would make sense
yeah what would you consider
insufferable in a woman
Tom oh [__] there's a lot of [__]
that's ins that well yeah that's what
that's what I'm curious about it's like
uh
just out of curiosity I don't know just
out of curiosity I don't know I can't
even [__] think of it you know it
when you see
it it's like pornography yeah you know
when you see it yeah Tammy said she was
actually married to Jesse James and he
cheated on her yeah so I was kind of
right keep it classy Jesse Yeah but yeah
she wasn't all that
evidently or or he was just a dick yeah
he was a dick too he was a dick that
dude was a dick I mean I've heard that
he a dick I I don't know him in real
life either but I'm just saying he
always seemed kind of like a dick to be
honest but um yeah they were talking
about we went to school together really
yeah because his shop was behind where
where my middle school was in
Dominguez I think he I think that shop
ended up being right behind Dominguez
elementary school and he was from the
area right there in Carson so we
probably went we probably went to
dominga elementary school
together Quinton Tarantino went to that
school with me too but he was a couple
years older than me but I remember him I
remember him but I remembered him
getting in trouble a lot but he was like
three or four years older than
me yeah yeah I remember you remember his
name and [__] everything I remember
seeing well that is a pretty um CU that
is his real name he didn't change it
that is a pretty uh distinctive name
yeah and then he uh Quinton worked at
the video story just just at the corner
just up the street from
school right near the Mexican
restaurant I think it was called el ran
Cheetos at the time which is a good
little Mexican restaurant wonder if it's
still there probably not I mean that was
a long time ago
yeah yeah Ian England said that had to
have been a match made in hell I can't
even like
imagine like I said I don't know either
of them in real life but that does seem
like a weird match the California
celebrity scenes real superficial they
date other [__] famous people I mean
that's who they're around all the time
and there's a lot
of there's a lot of [__] um abuse
going on because you have extremely rich
people in what's basically a ghetto a
lot of [__] the LA area is a
ghetto and the rich people are coming
from that ghetto so they
[Laughter]
just you could be in the middle of a
ghetto and drive [__] 15 minutes and
15 minutes to these streets and you end
up you seeing [__] mansions and [__]
it's a weird it's always been that way
it's a weird area
yeah that's how Hollywood had so much
power over the locals that's how they
recruit these young girls and [__] do
all this [__] Casting Couch action
and [__] like that those girls didn't
have any [__]
money and people would move
there well yeah everybody went there
from all over the country hoping to get
discovered right yeah and they usually
just ended up getting exploited or
murdered in some cases which I've
written about but uh I left there in
81 our family wasn't from there anyway
they moved there they were actually
Southern
family my mother was from Virginia my
dad was from
Mississippi but that's where you were
born though California yeah born to Lake
Wood Lakewood California my mom's from
Baltimore Maryland and my dad is from
Springfield
Tennessee that's where so I'm kind of
southernish and kind of Northern
also I was saying while you were in the
bathroom that one of these days we
should do a drag queen double feature
with Priscilla Queen of the Desert and
Tu Wang Fu Thanks for Everything Julie
numar which are both one of them is
Australian and one of them is American
but they both have a similar theme and
both of them are very good you set that
up I I won't remember any of that you
probably will like them I would think I
haven't seen tuang Fu in a long time but
I've seen Priscilla Queen of the Desert
multiple times and I love that [__]
movie it has what's his name from um
what's that fucker's name see I get
drunk and I can't remember actor names
anymore the dude that was whan in
Prometheus oh uh yeah that guy with that
guy was in it yeah I forgot what his
name is Tammy was talking about an ABA
turd yeah yeah he had a turd from ABBA
that was one of the things that I
remember most from that movie Jam he she
loved [__] Eddie Murphy as Gumby yeah
it's Gumby Dam it yeah gumy damn it yeah
I remember that yeah it's pretty good I
mean [__] man back in the 80s like Eddie
Murphy was the [__] man yeah I must have
watched raw four bajillion times yeah
you watch it now it's not funny but it
was funny I mean it's still kind of
funny but it's just well comedy doesn't
age the same way as other things do like
it's very rare to see a comedy like an
old comedy yeah that's still funny you
know what I mean like a lot of times
you'll see some comedies like from the
80s or the 70s or something like that
and you're just like what you know what
I mean there are some but I okay I will
submit that from the 80s uh Ghostbusters
is still funny Ghostbusters is still
funny um but a lot of comedies from the
' 80s even ones that I thought were real
funny in the ' 80s if I watch them now
it's like it's not as funny anymore it's
just not funny history of the world
[__] Mel Brook's history of the world
isn't funny anymore I watch it and I was
just like although airplane is still
funny yeah airplane is funny I will
submit that airplane is still funny cuz
we watched that a couple years ago and
I'm like okay that's still funny yeah a
lot of M Brook stuff isn't funny
anymore just that type of humor just
kind of aged
out yeah comedy is really your threshold
was smaller back then yeah and in a way
it's kind of like it might be the
hardest genre to like
because that's
that I I feel like comedy ages worse
than any other genre like you can watch
a horror movie from the [__] 1920s
and that shit's still scary you know
what I mean you can watch a drama from
back then and it's still good but you
watch a comedy back then you're just
like what it doesn't make any sense to
you old Dave Shel is still funny because
a lot of that's just
storytelling yeah and I tend to like
comedians that don't I don't like
comedians that are too topical I don't
because it dates if they're just telling
funny stories or making observations
that doesn't date so that tends to be
you know that stays funny telling
stories about [__] and then it was
Charlie Murphy telling stories about
[__] Prince the time he was hanging
out with Prince that was [__]
hilarious that's Eddie Murphy's brother
and then [__] Dave Chappelle's
playing F he's playing [__] prince in
Charlie Murphy's story that was a
[__] great one you can't you can't
beat that one and I mean that is still
funny even if you don't really you kind
of have to know who Prince is yeah like
I said as as time goes on like you'll
lose that context I guess so in some
ways I think it's just better to yeah
make comedy out of like just Universal
truths or like Universal human
experiences it doesn't date as much but
you know if you make too many topical
references 30 years from now people are
going to watch that and be like what the
[__] are you talking about you know what
I mean so and I and some comedies that
you see nowadays like that still even
airplane did that to a to a smaller
degree where it's like they reference
stuff that was going on at the time like
in the late '70s or whenever that movie
was made and it's like nowadays people
would be like what are you talking about
like they don't understand the context
but a lot of that stuff is still funny
though it's better to just keep it
General Ian says it's the same way where
he lives there's a [__] a million
dollar what did they say right there is
a million dollar $10 million Mansions
five minutes away from a damn tweak
trailer park yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
Hollywood is like that too I then you
got that millionaire going to that
trailer park saying any of you girls
want to be a star you know that's a
recipe for disaster also Who's Got Drugs
yeah it's a recipe for disaster and
that's the way the LA area was like I
probably not like that anymore Hollywood
doesn't have the power it used
to and it's just uh but that's the way
it
was a lot of those those rich people or
a lot of those Rich famous people in the
Hollywood scene came from those local
ghettos
and they didn't have any skills really
so they had to do whatever the studios
said or if not they'd be thrown back
into those [__] ghettos and people
people will do a lot if you're
threatened with like hey we're just
going to Chuck you back on the street
and you'll be homeless again and then
you know so and it's not a new
phenomenon that went back to the 1920s
they were doing that like I said we were
talking about that on the other show
where Tom said hey if some like big oil
Chic or something like that like offered
you $250,000 to like go hang out with
them for a week and you had to [__] them
and stuff he's like yeah you better go
I'll like keep you I'll help I'll be
packing your bags you know what I mean
which like I said I don't ,000 want but
it's $250,000 sitting there counting the
[__] numbers going what can for just
like one week I could live for years and
years like on that yeah it would be
shitty but I could put up with it for a
week probably job like any other job
that's yeah and that's how I would
approach it yeah they they had me had me
going into combat zon so right where you
could get killed for a lot less yeah I
mean it's better than being as long as
the [__] was safe and I knew that
[__] you know she'd come back live
and [__] you know she's yeah I don't
want to get murdered or nothing right
yeah but it's like you know what I mean
we were talking about that with this uh
[__] what's going on now because of
Instagram and the
internet billion doll [__] oil
barrons the sons of billion dollar Oil
Barons have access to beautiful women
that don't have any money and that's for
disaster yeah anywhere in the world and
they you offer somebody a quarter of a
million dollars and then they give them
a $60,000 down payment so they can buy
clothes for the event [__] then
yeah and then that then that girl after
all that goes back to her little po dump
town and she's going to marry those
dudes in that area man her [__]
standards have been set awful High she's
never going to come back from that so
who knows what kind of [__] pressure
that what kind of forces are put on that
girl because these are girls in their
20s although I like to think because I'm
old now yeah it's not it's yeah so it's
not the same so I'd be like yeah I'll
just just give me my quarter of a
million dollars please and then I'm just
going to go back home and like live
happily for the rest of my life when
you're older without having to do that
crap ever when you're older you know
what you know what reality is sure you
have a but you you know what the
Baseline is I'm like wo I could pay off
on my credit cards and I can get a new
car but when you're in your 20s some
chick put in the saving when you're in
some when you're in your 20s chick's not
going to realize what an unusual
situation that was and how that's never
coming back oh I'm very aware that that
would never come back I would I would
very much take that as like this is a
onetime thing cuz like I said I don't
want to do that more than once that
would not be fun for me that would not
be fun at all but I totally understand
it because Jam said what would happen if
they do it to you and I says well I I
think I'd be have to [__] go well
like I said if I got to go you got to go
I just I would just try to change my
[__] uh thinking like I'm on in a
different role like a secret agent yeah
yeah yeah like I said you just have to
think [__] character I'm just on like
a short-term contract this is a job that
I have to do I'm undercover right yeah
undercover you got to do that like get
my [__] quarter of a million and just
look at it like that and then that [__]
never happen
yeah and then later on you don't have to
think about it anymore hopefully buy a
whole [__] Fleet of [__] Harley
Davis you got to compartmentalize that
[__] cuz like I said that would not be
fun I don't want to do that um it
doesn't sound like a lot of fun for me
but um but for $250,000 I would probably
put up with it as long as I could just
like forget about it when I came back
home you'd have fun you'd have fun cuz
the locations they were going at and
everything You' have fun at but that's
part of the normal I wouldn't know
anybody and it's just kind of like I
don't know it Jenny is a little bit of a
[__] web blanket when it comes to
like oh no but you you I'm not a wet
blanket I'm just saying I wouldn't know
anybody and it's like they probably
wouldn't have anything in common with me
they would probably not be cool it would
be real mundane that's what I mean it's
like I don't really like hanging out
with I don't really like hanging out
with like supern Normy people like that
so it's just kind of like it wouldn't be
fun for me and it's like oh and then
they have to then we have to like you
know exchange genitalia yeah okay go
restroom I'm just I'll put up with it
for2 $50,000 but for less than that I
probably would not cuz like I said it
doesn't it doesn't sound like for
everything it there is I I agree but
like I said I wouldn't enjoy it though
it wouldn't really sound like that much
fun like I said I'd have more fun like
probably like hanging out with the girls
than having to do [__] with the dude
because I don't know that [__] dude
it would be weird but you know what I
mean uh Tammy said I think that's why
Eddie isard is so funny yeah that's what
I always thought too he does stories
everyone can relate to or no knows
something about the subjects he brings
up that's one of the things that I was I
mean he's probably my favorite comedian
ever um and I think that's why because
he doesn't really tell jokes I don't
really like comedians that just like
tell jokes that like set up punch line
all that kind of stuff I like ones that
are like storytellers and Eddie isard
seems to do like a lot of even though I
don't I don't know how much of his stuff
is like improvised but it seems very
improv like the way that he goes about
things and I know that he kind of like
works on his stuff like as The Show Goes
On like he does a lot of improv type
stuff and he just like tells stories and
a lot of them kind of go in like real
Surreal directions but you can still
kind of like follow him into those
directions and that's like very funny to
me like all of the stuff that he does is
great I mean every single show of his
that I've seen has been [__]
hilarious I don't think I've laughed so
hard as I did the first time I saw dress
to kill um I think I just almost had a
[__] heart attack laughing at how
[__] funny that was I mean that's
just like and I've watched it like many
many times since that I have it watching
what Eddie isard I have like a bunch of
um of their stuff I have dress to kill I
have um what was the one before that
Circle I have Circle which was after
that I think that was two mid
2000s um but I have like most of their
stuff and it's just like oh my God so
[__] funny is just like [__]
hilarious yeah Hugo weaving is also in
um Priscilla Queen of the Desert I can't
believe you never seen that that's so
good I love that [__]
movie um thank you very much l hey I'm
super late but Jenny have you announced
you're doing another live for tomes of
Terror flickers of fear yet um I'm GNA
do I've actually watched it and kind of
written out what I want to say about it
I think I'm going to do it on Sunday I'm
going to do somebody requested that I do
the 1981 movie fear no evil and I found
that on shudder so I watched it
yesterday and so I'll probably do like a
stream about it on Sunday gonna say like
right for me I didn't love it but it's
interesting if you're really into like
religious horror like if you liked the
omen or something like that then you'd
probably dig this but
it's out there it's a little bit out
there going to say I shared a song with
you on [__] Instagram I sent you um
Death in June be death in Rome pump up a
jams their version of that you would
like
that I had not realized that death in
Rome have so many cu I've heard a lot of
their covers yeah yeah but they have so
many that I haven't like listened to yet
so what that is is they're they're a
cover band they cover pop songs but they
do it but they like
Uber goth fashion Uber Gothic
Germanic [__] they're so great it's
so great yeah folk way it's so great
they're doing it in the the Death in
June style that was the original band
that did that it was called uh Neo folk
Gothic neofolk right and it's like so
they're aping Death in June but they
have their own thing going on too and
they're and they usually take a song
yeah that is like an 80s pop song or
they did some '90s pop they'll take like
a real upbeat one but they'll like make
it real down make like a durge make it
real down beat I love it they did um
Love is a Battlefield which I think is
probably my favorite pump up the jams
they did pump up the jams they did
Barbie girl the aqua song did [__] uh
Careless Whispers Careless Whisper the
Wham song um Take On Me they did they
did a really cool version of that yeah
they did cures
disintegration well see now that's kind
of like a lateral move though that was
already kind that was already kind of
athy song but I I kind of like when they
take the ones that are were like super
upbeat like pop songs yeah and like turn
them into like Gothic Jes yeah it's all
this Germanic [__] drums and
[__] socialist sounding [__] I think
Love is a Battlefield is probably my
favorite the pat banar song that's
[__] great I love that so much it's
on my it's on my phone actually we
listen to in the car sometimes the sign
I saw oh that's right yeah who did that
[__] song I forgot I wanted to say rock
set but I don't think it's I sent her
the sign and I sent her [__] pump of
the
jam classic [__] that's a [__] to listen
to We we danc to that [__] we got Paul
Bain at yeah mannequins to play death in
R's version of pp up the champ yeah I'm
we were the only two people that danced
to it yeah we played it early though he
played it early plays it too early he
play if he played it later when
everybody was dancing they'd do it he
knows that I'll go out and dance on my
own early at the night so he'll play
that [__] [__] I mean I'll dance by
myself I don't care I got more room at
least I don't have like a bunch of
douches like trying to like get in my
[__] way right so yeah but yeah so
he'll play like good [__] like he'll
play like Nick Cave or something like
that check it out tonight yeah you'll
like it then you follow you can follow
those links back to their [__] I've
talked to them before they're they're
good dudes and uh they got [__] 30 or
40 songs they're in
Germany [__] they had one where they
came down in a damn [__] real saucer
which is like a German World War II
[__] Flying Saucer that they had
[__] this [__] and I said where'd you
get that they go we got it off eBay of
course yeah they had a CG version of
them coming out of the [__] Flying
Saucer yeah yeah they're very into like
that old like Germanic Pagan yeah
Germanic Pagan like you know kind of
[__] looking brown shirt kind of
looking but they're poking fun at it too
yeah yeah it's like it's super funny
yeah like funny but like in a dark way
in a in a dark like Darkly funny but I
don't know I dig it you know what I mean
yeah Macky Max said Scientology has a
foothold in Hollywood Boulevard yeah
they do yeah there's a YouTuber trolling
their staff every day and night I think
he calls himself Streets of LA whatever
whatever happened to um the angry gay
Pope is he still out there doing he
makes comments on my videos he's on my
yeah he's on Facebook so he's on my
Facebook like I know real name but if I
ever [__] post any muscle [__]
videos he's like Stop
Shaving like no man we talking about he
told you to stop shaving man I gota get
Jen to clip clip my back yeah I grow
hair every [__] we ridiculous it's
not that bad but yeah you do have a
hairy bag yeah you got to [__] you
got you you know doing what I do you got
to
[__] I pull the Clippers out [__]
J [__] clip my bag yeah shave yeah
[__] [__] gets nasty gays love it
though gays like Harry man you're like a
bear yeah yeah yeah well what do you
think Zach what is it what what is up
with all this hairiness and [__] okay so
you're ask is so Zach is like the token
gay so you're asking yeah z z Zach is
the token gay hay or not hairy like as
far like like we're talking about backs
now yeah he shaves everything else I
shave everything I shave everything he's
he's ha try to keep shrimp but he can't
do the he can't do his back by himself
so I have to do it I have to do it yeah
the gays are always telling me to
[__] let everything grow they're in
these hairy [__] you I'm not
I'm like ambivalent um I don't like I
you know I don't want you looking like
Sasquatch but I don't really like I
don't a little bit of hair doesn't not
angry gay Pope tells me stop sh hair
does not bother and [__] same same
thing same thing with [__] um [__]
my boy [__] uh who Toby Toby yeah oh
he says stop Shing yeah yeah but then I
look at [__] Toby and Toby's not all
that hairy either I said yeah you don't
have hair on your back
though you well you know I'm not I don't
know I'm not bothered like it doesn't it
doesn't gross me Toby's not even on test
I personally like on myself do not like
to have hair but I don't really care if
other people do it doesn't really bother
me like I'm not I'm not bothered by it
one way loves Nick Cave that's crazy
he's my favorite like honestly I love
Nick Cave because she's got a Nick Cave
poster right there I got a Nick Cave
poster right back
from Germany can you see it from there
right there yeah yeah yeah see it says
[__] Nick Cave in the bad Seas right
there and it's all in German it was like
from a German show that he did yep and
honestly I'm probably like a bigger like
I love his solo [__] um but I'm probably
a bigger fan of the birthday party um I
just love that
[__] crazy [__] Post Punk energy
that they had um his solo [__] I really
like it up until he started to like
mellow out some which you you know like
I said that's what happens when you get
older and I do like his more mellow [__]
it's kind of grown on me more like as
I've gotten older but to be honest like
my favorite [__] of his solo stuff is
probably like his real early [__] I mean
his first album from her to Eternity I
love that [__] album I listen to it
all the time it's very
rudimentary but I don't know I'm just
kind of into it like all that [__]
[__] [__] that was on it like his
cover of Leonard Cohen's Avalanche was
[__] great I love that [__] cover
St Huck was great like that whole
[__] album is so good and um I love
the blues album that he did firstborn is
dead that's also fantastic um probably
my favorite album theirs though I think
was Henry's dream which I think came out
in
92 um that's probably the one I listen
to the most out of all of the solo stuff
I have all his stuff though I like that
album they had what was it called murder
stories murder ballads murder ballads
that's great too that was 96
I want to say that came out in 96 that's
also great St yeah his cover of
staggerly I [__] love and like I said
we go to mannequins and they play that
and he'll play that for me because he
knows I love that song what's one with a
red right hand that was on let love in
which was 94 yeah that was that what's
in that song red right hand yeah it's
called red right hand okay yeah that was
like the um theme song of scream
although the song came out before that
yeah but that is also a great album
probably my second favorite yeah that's
another time when you got foreigners
[__] uh [__] fantasizing about
living in the
South ni loves the South he's Australian
and he's Australian and they have a
thing about like Amer but because Nick
Cave I mean even from a young age even
from the birthday party days when he was
like in his [__] teens and 20s he was
real into yeah uh Southern blue singers
yeah um and even later on he did an
album Delta um called Kicking against
the Pricks yeah which was was um which
is a Bible quote and he did covers of
songs that he really loved and a lot of
them were Blues covers like he did um
Hey Joe he did um I'm G to kill that
woman which I think was originally Muddy
Waters and he did like a bunch of Blue
songs like he did like some Velvet
Underground and she like like he did all
tomorrow's parties and stuff like that
but some of the fir I think probably the
first goth
song was a delta Mississippi delta blues
song called I Put a Spell on
You yeah I would say that was Gothic and
it wasn't old Howland James he wasn't
the first one that did it I heard the
yeah uh he he covered that there was a
dude that [__] well all of those
songs were way older they're way older
yeah because people Mississippi boo yeah
people would like take song like record
them that songs that hadn't been
recorded for that was the [__] Elvis was
hearing when he was a kid going man I
got to bring this [__] to the [__]
mainstream and that's that's what it was
if you go listen to the original version
of I Put a Spell on You it's good good
real good I've heard the I think that
was 20s maybe 30s yeah all of them are
like really old recordings are out there
they're on YouTube Tammy said red right
hand is also the opening song for the
show peaky blinders which we still
haven't watched like we've had it
recommended to us like so many times
also has Tom Hardy oh [__] we should
watch that then yeah yeah red right hand
like I said I think a lot of people know
that song because it was the kind of
unofficial theme song of Scream the
original West Craven one that came out
in 96 or whenever that came out uh that
album came out in '94 though and that I
mean I will admit that is a great song
that's not my favorite song off that
album I think my favorite song off that
album is probably the opening one which
is called do you love me um which is
still that's a [__] fantastic song I
love that [__] album too
but I think that's probably why because
they do actually play that at clubs and
a lot of people do seem to know that
song I think it's mostly from Scream but
might be from peeky blanders too
uh Lil movie said my boyfriend
introduced me first song I heard was
she's hit oh my God I love that [__]
song My Favorite birthday party song
though is
swampland swampland is my favorite
birthday party song um
although Jennifer's Veil is a close
second I don't know it goes back and
forth I love Jennifer's Veil also really
that whole the last EP they did um which
was just called
Mutiny uh I think it was only what was
it only four songs four songs six songs
something like that but all of the songs
in there were [__] fantastic uh
Jennifer's Veil and Mutiny in heaven are
[__]
great but yeah Swan plan easily my
favorite birthday party song but
Jennifer's Veil second
second yeah hi do said I love swamp plan
my favorite is mut yeah mut happ's great
too like I have it on my phone and it's
like every time it comes on I'm just
like [__]
signal they were so [__] weird I
loved them I love them I mean that was
so [__] good they were
just it was just kind of like um I don't
even I don't even know how to describe
it it's kind of it's Blues influenced
obviously but it's also Post Punk
influenced and it's also kind of just
like
Madness influenced and Drug
influenced and I've never really heard
anything like it
before or
since it's they're very singular like
they don't really sound like anyone else
and I'm just like really into it but
like I said Nick Cave is really kind of
one of my
personal Heroes I guess because not only
is he a great [__]
songwriter but he's also written a
couple of novels which were fantastic
and also kind of crazy um first one
being and the ass saw the angel and he
also wrote one called the death of bunny
Monroe which I feel like a lot of people
don't talk about all that much but I've
read it and it's and it's good uh it's
not as good as in the Assa the angel
though
that that book was
like um very William Faulkner esque I
want to
say so it's kind of out there but if you
like William fogner if you like Southern
Gothic then you'd probably like be super
into it because he was very into like
Old Testament imagery you know what I
mean like he was real into that kind of
[__] and I was like really in so like I
don't you know I'm an atheist I don't
believe in any of that kind of stuff but
it's like I love all of the like
iconography around that kind of stuff
and like the whole thing he did like
like on um firstborn his dad which was
his second solo album with the bad seeds
he did a song called Tupelo which was
basically
comparing the birth of Elvis with the
birth of Jesus but it was done like
seriously like like myth making and it
was just like [__] brilliant like the
um the lyrics for for that are [__]
brilliant I think he's one of the best
songwriters
ever you
know so see we got some other like Nick
Haven birthday party fans in there so
I'm not just a
nerd what's that I'm not just a nerd
yeah we got some other the movie said
her boy her boyfriend introduced her to
yeah yeah yeah first time was yeah she's
it yeah she's hit that's a great [__]
song I love that song but I told her
swampland was my favorite
yeah and then High Desert said I love
swampland also it said my favorite is
muty Heaven which is probably that's
probably that's got to be in my top five
although man all their songs are so
[__] good I really like um they did
one called say a spell and it's really
hard to find it
nowadays um but it's I really really
like that one too I don't know if you I
mean I'm sure you probably heard that
one but that's another one of my
favorite ones called Z
spell really really good so who's your
boyfriend mover where did he hear uh uh
Nick K birthday party birthday party and
all that that was his old band yeah yeah
he must be an old guy you're that he's
cool young guy or a cool young guy yeah
yeah it's hard to tell these days
because like I said we've met some fck
young people that know all kind of 19 20
year olds that know all of that [__] you
know that [__] and they're go oh yeah
yeah and they name all the people in the
band and everything and all the albums
are God well in a way that's kind of
cool because I was talking to my brother
about this because he did not he was
flabbergasted cuz he's only years than I
am and he's into a lot of the same music
as me he was in a punk band back in the
day and [__] like that so I told him we
were going to my our grandma's funeral
and we were riding together so we were
talking about that and I said bro he
doesn't go out anymore you know he's
married he has kids and stuff like that
so I was kind of like we have met 18 19
20-year-old kids that know all of the
old music and sometimes like know more
about it than I know about it which is
saying
something and
I was like it's kind of cool like cuz
for them I mean for us for them it's an
old it's ancient history for them well
yeah but for them they're not sick of it
either yeah like for them it's almost
kind of like yeah it's old but it's also
like brand new for us you go to a club
and you hear I don't know this corrosion
or something like that and you're like
oh here's like I love that song but it's
like oh here's this song again we've
been hearing that for [__] 40 years
you know what I mean but for them it's
not like that it's like they might have
just discovered that song a year or two
ago so it's new for them she answered me
in two Place Rec um yeah he's older but
I'm older than I look he's a punk metal
band member okay yeah oh okay yeah yeah
yeah then he's into surreal art too yeah
okay see that's awesome that how how old
are you guys how old are you and her I
mean just curious just curious yeah yeah
but so yeah M looked like she was in her
20s to me mid you look very young from
the video that I saw of you
yeah yeah High Desert said I've never
seen Nick Cave live unfortunately I
haven't either the only time that I ever
had the possibility was I had bought
tickets to laala palooza in 1994 they
were playing at the fairground in Dand I
had tickets I was super excited um Nick
Haven the bad seeds were playing I was
also excited about L7 because I liked
them I don't remember what other bands
were on it um but I was super jazzed the
morning of the show I wake up and it had
rained the whole previous night and the
fairground flooded and the stage sank
into the mud and they canel it on the
morning and they didn't reschedule so I
never got to see him now my sister who
was seven years younger than me and also
a big Nick Cave fan has seen him
multiple times because she lives in
actual cities where he actually plays um
so I'm kind of jealous about that she's
seen him at least three or four times I
think and she always likes to rub it in
she's like oh my God it was so awesome
and I'm like oh my God you suck I've
he's 30 he's 36 oh y'all are still
youngsters you guys live here in
Florida hi deser said a chick I Used to
Know introduced me to the birthday party
when I was 15 she became a junkie later
yeah that probably happened a lot you
know yeah Nick Cave being a big heroin
addict
although he did um get over it I guess
he was one of the ones that didn't die
young right
that I've never known a guy who is
hooked up just walk away from it like
that though they take little vacations
away from it well he has said and I mean
he's probably I don't know how old he is
now but he's probably like in his 60s I
would imagine he's older than me yeah a
long time and he said that he's like
well I read an interview with him a few
years ago and he said I think that
because of all the problems I had with
heroin and all that other kind of stuff
he's like I think I want like everybody
wants me to come out and say you know
don't do drugs drugs are bad things he's
like but I don't think drugs are bad
things yeah he's like you know sometimes
you can do them and it's fun and it's
fine and stuff like that and you know um
and I don't think I you know I don't
know about nowadays now that he's older
but you know it I didn't get the
impression that he stopped taking them
entirely I just think that he has like a
better handle on it well that's like
what Billy Idol says right yeah Billy
Idol he just he's not as crazy as he was
he still does stuff I think everyone is
one of the ones that I and that's the
thing when you get older that's kind of
one of the nicer things about getting
older is that you're not you got less to
lose well one you have less to lose and
you have like more control over yourself
so it's just kind of like you can do
some [__] and go crazy and stuff like
that but it's like man I don't have to
do that again like for a while you know
what I mean you don't get sucked into it
the same way that you get sucked into it
when you're younger yeah you know so I
kind of feel like that's maybe the case
with and honestly like I you know Nick
Cave still looks f [__] good like for
as old as he is yeah uh he didn't get
fat um you know he didn't bloat out or
anything like that like some other rock
stars that we could name um just kind of
same as Iggy Pop like he probably took
all the drugs back in the old days but
he looked pretty fantastic like like he
looks like an old man but he looks like
a cool old man yeah not getting fat is a
big thing yeah keeping weight off you
yeah I I think that helps a
lot well it's kind of like Billy Idol he
looks old now he doesn't look as good as
he did 15 years ago he looks pretty old
but he's not fat so he can still pull it
off and you know he's still got a lot of
fans and I like seeing him and he's kind
of made a good transition into the
internet world where instead of
releasing albums he's just releasing
singles on YouTube and still touring
yeah I mean you know and making single
videos which is that's how people do it
now and he's I'm sure he has enough of a
fan base that that would like probably
sustain him yeah he just has to tour
sure you know he tours and and you could
even do like smaller clubs and Sh sure
that's the thing and I I kind of feel
like a lot of 8s bands do that because
there's a lot of old [__] like us and
well and not just old [__] but like I
said younger [__] that just
discovered the music I mean he's a
grandad yeah and video he owns his own
house now and he's doesn't he doesn't I
don't think he really needs the money I
think everything's paid
for I think yeah I think the houses he
owns it I would have hoped so it would
really bum me out if somebody that was
that famous back in the day like now had
to [__] Scrabble for money that would
he's doing pretty that would really like
bum me out he did a single just a a year
or so back called roadside you can see
the video and everything on on YouTube
it's great it's great song used to play
it at the uh
I put the Oasis for the bikers I put
roadside on they [__] loved it they
that's Billy Idol yeah they they you
know oh yeah yeah I even liked his
Christmas album that yeah got we got a
good man we got to play the Christmas
album where is it I don't know what'd
you do with it it's around here
somewhere it's around here somewhere
yeah I got his album yeah we got we got
his Christmas album like last year or
the year before somebody I think Tammy
bought the Christmas album too I think I
think yeah yeah I like it yeah I like
that Christmas Al Billy Idol's [__]
Christmas album I mean everybody got to
do a Christmas album you know what I
mean all right I gotta pee okay go you
talk talk about something I'll be back
in a minute I'll talk about something
I'll tell you what I'll talk about talk
about how hungry I
am I made some
uh butter chicken Indian butter chicken
made it made it last night it's even
better today I probably got a gallon of
that [__]
left I think I used eight chicken
breasts in it so there's a lot of food
down there with basmati rice waiting on
me so I'm sit here doing the show
drinking going getting
hungry I'm not in the Christmas spirit
yet for some reason it's not really
Dawning on me that it's [__]
Christmas I'm buying Christmas gifts for
everybody sent Christmas gift to [__]
S I got Christmas gifts for Jen my mom I
got buying [__] for people I'm just not
really in the in the Christmas spirit
yet
of the house I got the projectors and
everything just ready ready to go I
just been busy been busy out there
[__] tearing [__] [__] out doing
yard work gonna make that [__]
display out in the front put a new
[__] Garden in there what whatever
you call it and uh try to increase the
value of this [__]
house we'll sell this [__] off in
another [__] s or eight years of me
and Jen [__] split to the Philippines
and live like [__] Kings we have
talked about doing that yeah like maybe
moving to another country where it was
like much cheaper yeah cu the
Philippines is a us
protectorate so my VA money can be sent
to the
Philippines and I make two grand a
[__] month just VA [__] free
money and that's a [__] ton of money in
[__] in the
Philippines you know that's enough
that's a lot and then with the show and
the other things that we do online we
can still do the show from the
Philippines yeah that's kind of the
nature of the so we can do the [__] from
anywhere we continue to work we could do
this show from anywhere we could do porn
from anywhere I can do graphic design
from anywhere yeah so that's what's nice
about I'm just trying to put you know
it's not time but when a time comes I
want to put The Feelers out to see where
a good place would go to move it might
be Philippines might be
Mexico Mexico might be cool too CU they
got a much much better goth scene Mexico
City they do have a really good G city
in Mexico but I think the Philippines is
even cheaper than Mexico it is at least
now right right
now I mean you can buy a [__] Palace
for $150,000 in [__]
Philippines that's what it's like you
know [__] making $2,000 a month in
the Philippines is the equivalent to be
making like $6,000 a month here that you
know and your credit's my credit is
fantastic so you know I gotta
relationship with the bank I could just
fcking finance a a home and have a home
constructed see that's another thing I
could do yeah we have a thing been
researching the other dudes that are
doing it yeah you know cuz that's
something we've been like discussing for
the future yeah and a lot of [__] VA
guys if you listening to me murder
Hornet that's another [__] VA guy
he's on VA [__] you got to live in
United States you don't have to live in
United States you can move somewhere
like much cheaper yeah which we've been
thinking that money goes a lot further
further in the
Philippines because it's a us
protectorate they won't shut off your
[__] flow or your money which I
wouldn't mind living in Philippines it
it looks nice and they have really good
food there the people are real nice
that's what I've heard people are real
nice and friendly and there's no real
crime and you get a lot for your money
and a lot of fun and they do have clubs
there they even have [__] fetish
clubs and [__] like that so they have
like I said I want like a low stress
like style yeah and you just wind down
over in the Philippines sure yeah Lil
movie said um they're in Tennessee
they're in Tennessee okay when I visit I
will see y'all my father's side of the
family is from Tennessee so I've been
there a few times yeah I was over at uh
in Clarksville and my brother used to
live there too I was in Clarksville when
I was in the 101st he used to go to
Nashville all the time then I had a
friend of mine from Detroit actually
moved to
Nashville so uh yeah I like Tennessee
Tennessee is kind of like the big city
of Mississippi if you're Mississippi I'm
going move to the big city what are you
talking about Nashville Nashville yeah
sure Nashville
Clarksville High Desert said I love
Andrew eldrich he's still thin but his
voice is shot I also love Robert Smith
his voice hasn't changed but he's fat
now yeah yeah I mean Robert Smith um
let's be charitable he doesn't he
doesn't look too great now he looks like
[__] but he seems like he doesn't really
give a he doesn't have to give a [__]
his music is still really good his shows
are boring though shit's still good
though yeah the music's really good his
shows are boring he's probably like
stand there I don't care what it look
like the Cure is still a great band oh
yeah and their music is [__] great
who would have thought I never would
have thought because I got into the Cure
in the early 80s yeah and I never would
have thought that they'd still be
[__] going yeah little mover if you
want to hear some good music man this
many years later and they're still good
yeah little mov get a get a cure album
so one of the old classic cure albums
like Kiss kiss me kiss me kiss me
disintegration or [__] uh head on the
wall or head the head on the door
pornography is favor the best album
right but I mean that's like super like
Gothic that's old yeah real old [__] 82
that came out that's still my favorite
album Faith was good yeah Faith was good
too yeah pornography is still my
favorite right I have like I don't know
I have a lot of other favorites but
that's still my f that's still the one
that I revisit the
most you know yeah I listen to a lot of
their other ones but that's the one I
revisit the most because it's just
that's the one if I'm going to listen to
the whole album yeah I can listen to the
whole thing although kiss me kiss me
kiss me is like that too which is weird
because that one is just like 10
different styles yeah but somehow it all
still hangs together like as one thing
which is amazing yeah move if you you
and your man come down to visit in
Florida go ahead and [__] contact us
we'll see what we could
do yeah that would be super fun actually
yeah we'll show you guys where to go and
ship yeah yeah we'll all we'll go
clubbing it'll be super fun it'll be
super fun yeah I'm super excited that
you're like into the cave too cuz I
don't get to geek out about that Tom
like like you like some of his songs but
like some of his stuff I don't like
you're not like super into some of his
gospel yeah he's real into and I like
that yeah um I like that like it's not
usually something that I would like but
I don't know I kind of dig it his gospel
can kind of get on my nerves but all
gospel gets them on nerves that's why
one of the reasons why I don't really I
like Elvis as a guy I don't really like
his music because most of his music was
gospel yeah well Nick K was a big Elvis
fan too but Elvis had some good songs
man [__] if [__] dream was a
[__] good one uh a lot of his old
rock and roll stuff was pretty good um
but a lot of Elvis's music was [__]
gospel yeah even though I know it was
good gospel I just don't like gospel
well I mean Nick Cave his stuff is a lot
of his early stuff is Gospel
inspired um he didn't really do a what I
would call a gospel
album
until um he did one that what the [__]
was that one that came out in the 90s
that had um the weeping song on it I'll
tell you one thing that had a song
called the witness song on it that was
straight up gospel but that is an
awesome [__] song cave could capture
the gothic feel the vibe the sound yeah
no matter what he's Sayang it had a
Gothic t to it the Goths
light well and like I said he was I like
him cuz he's real into like he's
Australian so he didn't grow up in this
culture yeah but he really is
into Southern Gothic yeah like not just
the music like he likes all the blues
and Elvis and stuff like that but he's
into like the literature like I said
like William fogner flaner O Conor like
stuff like that he's into that whole
gastal I guess
and he's really good even though he's
not even from here he's very good at
like conveying that in like in a way
that's like crazy to me that he wasn't
born
here yeah what's funny is if you're born
in the South you take it for granted but
the the South itself me being from a
southern family that's moved everywhere
and I've lived in other countries and
just come the south is a very special
place it has its own vibe
to yeah and and I like it although I
could live
anywhere I like the South if I'm gonna
live in the United States it's gonna be
in the South if I'm gonna live in South
America it's GNA be in Brazil all right
if I was going to live in Central
America it'd be somewhere in Mexico
maybe Mexico City in the goth scene
there if I was live in the Far East I
don't think I'd go back to Korea because
I lived in Korea already I'd probably go
to the
Philippines we' talked about no interest
in Japan everybody's all interested
about Japan I I would mind visiting
Japan but it seems kind of expensive to
live there and it's generic uh that
that's that's just a big urban place you
know there are country places in Japan
maybe I'd probably like those better but
um I don't like places that are highly
civilized and homogenized and I like
places that are a little wilder than
that you know and the South has that
Central and South America and places
have
that Philippines seems to have that you
know I like the offbrand you know what I
mean yeah I like the off brand
stuff Hi Desert said C made a cameo in
that Jesse James movie with Brad Pit
yeah he he played um what was the name
of his
character well he's been in a couple
movies he was in one called ghost of the
Civil dead which was a Australian
film he was in that movie he played a
character called storm something in that
Brad Pit movie but I can't remember what
it is right now also he's done scores
for a lot of movies and he wrote the
screenplay for a western called The
Proposition which was actually very very
good super super violent which like I
said if you know anything about him you
won't be surprised like when I saw it I
was like oh of course this is very Nick
you know what I mean yeah the
proposition yeah that was a great
[__] movie I really like that a lot
what the [__] was the name of that movie
with Brad Pit in
it yeah Nick Cave was in it and he and
he had like a um God damn it he had like
a big white
pador [__] man what was the name of that
movie I saw it a couple times somebody
will remember like I said I I get drunk
and I can't like remember [__] but I
know I've seen it um but yeah it was
really good
but and I think right around the same
time right around the same time he was
in Ghost of the Civil dead which like I
said I've actually never seen because
it's an Australian movie and it's kind
of hard to get a hold of that was when
he did The Mercy Seat video
which I love The Mercy Seat Johnny Cash
covered that song which is [__] crazy
to me he did something different with it
he did something more like the version
that's on the album which is called
tender
prey is a lot different when he would do
live shows when Nick C do live shows
later on like I have a live album um
called live seeds that he did and he did
a version of Mercy seed on there that
was kind of closer to the version that
Johnny Cash would do later it was kind
of more like
a folky kind of version I guess I love
Johnny Cash's version too but I don't
know if a lot of people know what the
original sounds like because it doesn't
sound anything like the the album
version doesn't sound anything like the
Johnny Cash version but the Johnny Cash
version is good too but like I said Nick
Cave would do like a more folky version
of The Mercy Seat later on which like I
said that song
was
about like I said he was very into like
Old Testament imagery that song was
about a man who
was on death
row and he was in the electric chair and
the whole thing was an extended metaphor
about the electric chair being like the
like God's seat of judgment so it was
very like Old Testament but it was also
kind of about a dude like getting
executed like for murder you know what I
mean so it it's oh so I I loved that he
would take [__] like that but like put
it like in an Old Testament like
biblical kind of context I don't know I
just really liked I don't know I just
really like that whole like [__]
situation and like I said I think he's
one of the best songwriters like ever
like his lyrics his lyrics are [__]
fantastic love
them um and he's written like a bunch of
books of his lyrics as well like poems
and stuff I want to see that movie that
Czechoslovakian movie
what's it called The Undertaker the
embalmer oh the one that was in the um
yeah the death in BR video yeah yeah
Little M that one of those videos that I
sent you the second one yeah that music
video is made up out of a movie a
Czechoslovakia movie that post World War
II about it oh no excuse me before World
War II really started a guy who is it's
about a Nazi and he kills his own family
members because they're part Jewish and
he he owns a damn funeral home it's a
horror movie yeah I want to see it it's
called Uh I think it's called the
embalmer that's what that movie yeah you
can probably find it we were looking for
it yeah uh we were looking for we got
we'll find
it but it's not an English language it's
in
Chad we'll find it
yeah Ben says they say it's a
masterpiece I mean it looks cool black
and white
Ben who is from uh New Zealand has seen
ghost of the Civil dead which is cool
because I want to see it uh it's a
prison movie it's pretty good there's a
guy who gets beaten up and has [__]
tattooed on his forehead he wears a
bandana after that I guess as you would
um but yeah that's one movie that I've
actually been wanting to see a lot
because I know that that was something
that Nick Cave was
in and there was like I said in The
Mercy Seat video which they showed on um
what was that show they used to have on
MTV 120
minutes um they used to show that a lot
back in
1988 and I remember hearing a lot about
that movie but I never got to see it you
know what I mean but Nick's been in a
couple of movies but he's written some
movies too and written like scores for
them
um yeah so yeah so Ben's seen it one of
these days I'll see it somebody send me
a
copy that'll play like on an American
thing how long should have been going on
um 2 hours and 36 minutes okay I don't
know I'm having a good time we're not
going anywhere I'm
hungry yeah I'm kind of hungry too but I
still got some drink left I still have
some drink left we'll finish his drinks
though you going to have more butter
chicken or you going to or you going to
make something else butter chicken I
mean that butter chicken is like I got a
bunch of it down there you were making
it the other day you didn't tell me
ahead of time that you were making it
but it's like I was up here working and
I smelled or something I was like yeah
that smelled like butter chicken yeah I
hope that's butter chicken it smelled
like you make really good butter chicken
thank you gonna say we tried out I
forgot I think we forgot to mention this
we tried out a new Indian restaurant
yeah that's right last weekend yeah in
Mount Dora yeah because we we got up
Saturday and we're kind of like man you
know what I don't really feel like going
to the Chinese buffet today let's go to
a new place like a place we haven't been
to before so we kind of went on Google
and looked around I was like what's
around here Tom's like hey there's an
Indian restaurant called Shiva in Mount
Dora maybe we should try that out they
don't have a buffet like we couldn't
determine if they had a buffet or they
had a buffet but not on those days they
did but like not on the day that we went
so we went there it's a small place like
it's the size of this room yeah it
looked big like in the pictures but it's
not um and I'm going to say like the
service is slightly slow yeah but the
food was really good the food was really
good I got um it was expensive though a
little bit yeah little bit I think we
paid almost 60 bucks for two of us which
for Florida that's well with a tip it
was
573 55 something like that and in
Florida that's that's expensive but I'm
going to say that was
two well we also got like the um got a
the Nan and I think that was $7 on Zone
$7 for bread yeah yeah it's a little
steep it is a little bit Yeah the food
was good though I got lamb corma you got
chicken Cora chicken Cora that's right
and it was like really really good I was
curious because one of our favorite
Indian restaurants in Central FLorida is
memories of India which we have to go
back to soon yeah which is in Lake Mary
yeah and they do a lamb corma that is
out of this [__] world yeah it's real
spicy though but it's well no it's not
you can get it mild I usually get it
mild but the thing about their lamb
corma Brown yeah it's very very Brown
and it has um slivered almonds yeah in
the sauce which I'm all
about um I don't think memories of India
is actual Indian food but it tastes good
well like I said everybody's got their
and the thing about it is that India is
a big country right so it's just kind of
like whatever Indian restaurant you go
to I mean wherever that Chef is from
like whatever region of India that's
from the like the recipes are going to
be we have seen Indian people in there
eating it yeah yeah yeah so it's just so
yeah so so I was
curious um to get lamb corma at this
other place cuz I was like oh well I
always get lamb corma at memories of
India and I want to see like how it was
different you know what I mean cuz it
and it was a lot different but it was
still like really good it was yellow
instead of brown yeah it seemed like a
lot more turmeric heavy yeah whereas the
one at memories of India is a lot more
garam masala is a lot more garam masala
and like I said had like slivered
almonds and stuff like that I still will
say the memories of India one is better
but the one at shivo was it's still
pretty good yeah just different I don't
know if the if the cost was
effective I'd rather go to [__]
memories of India for that price well
memories of India um they're slightly
expensive but you get a lot like they
honestly I think they give you the they
give you the naan for free right it just
comes with it yeah and and they have a
they have a buffet on the weekends
remember on Sundays they do and they
have like a they have a champagne brunch
yeah champagne like they give you like
the um what do you call the that's what
we're going we're going there this
weekend you want we're going to that
champagne brunch we're going to look
that [__] that's Sunday yeah I think
it's just Sunday might be Saturday too
I'm not sure yeah I remember just eating
till we just filled to the [__] gills
man going you know the struggle to go
home and [__] but [__] we're we're both
on gear we can eat
[__] we can eat food till [__] our
heart's desire not really put on any fat
well I mean I can't eat that much food
anyway because I'm just kind of like I
can't really eat that much one time's
room but there's no room because I'm
just like yeah I'm just gonna throw up
so yeah y'all need to [__] see Jen
you all gonna see it soon Jenny's
[__] body is looking so [__]
fantastic she's [__] looking better
than I've ever [__] seen her her
booty is is it ridiculous he was biting
it yesterday yeah biting it he kept
biting it I couldn't resist I went in
there like I was I was spotting him
[__] bite it yeah I was working out
cuz he was like doing like he was
lifting like really heavy weights and
stuff and so I went in there to
spot and then like I was leaving and I
had my little shorts on she had little
booty shorts on little booty shorts and
he's just like come here a second and
then he bit my ass yeah bit her on it I
could resist
it and then make a video and then like
later on we're like laying in the room
and I was watching what was I watching I
was watching Master Chef Jor yeah the
Christmas edition sitting there start
[__] and he just keeps like rubbing
on it and keep like rubbing on it and
biting and stuff I'm like do you want me
to pause this or couldn't have we had to
pause it and put porn up yeah yeah then
it went
down just um although the porn the porn
that you picked was it sucked it sucked
I wasn't really watching it you know
yeah I was really watching there was
really nothing to
see but um the uh I just want to have
some background [__] Ambiance going on
but anyway the uh porn Jen's Jen's
[__] hormonal Prof profile is [__]
causing her to [__] take a shape I've
never seen her before it's just her
shape is [__] getting furious man and
it happened fast two
months it just it did which is really
weird mons yeah and like I said it was
serious gear though I put I haven't
really noticed it all that much cuz you
know used to it yet I'm going take a
picture of it I've gotten comments
though like from other people yeah what
they
say excuse me I didn't get up that early
Jesus Christ um
remember I said the um that British guy
that watched us on streamate yeah he
actually like um messaged me the other
day and said hey I haven't seen you guys
on streamate in a while like are you
guys all right and what's going on and
blah blah blah so I was talking to him
for a while this
morning and um he's like he's seen some
of our older shows and he's like you
guys look a lot different nowadays than
you did back then and I was like yeah
we're like on hormones and all this
other kind of stuff and he's just like
you guys look amazing like nowadays so I
was just like yeah that's awesome ology
is a reality yeah and I got a a comment
the other day on one of my videos I
can't remember which one it was it might
have been one of on one of my scare
Salon ones yeah and they the person that
was commenting was like super excited
they're like not only are you super into
horror movies but you're also very funny
and you were also I think the term they
used was uncomfortably hot okay yeah all
right so I'm like okay I'll take it okay
I'm not really sure how to take that but
okay that was just from that was just
from the video that you made or was it I
don't remember what video it I think it
was one of my scar salon videos I think
it was the last one that I put up which
was my five favorite horror movies from
1982 it might have been that one yeah
okay cuz the weird thing about it is
that I post [__] over on my scar Salon
Channel yeah and some of those people
don't know about 13 o00 okay so they
must be just being recommended that
without right which like I said so I
always kind of try to say hey I have
like a channel over here where I do like
a
bajillion movie and book reviews that I
don't I try to cross post them like at
least put them in the um in the playlist
like on scar Salon I have a playlist
that's 13:00 book reviews 13 o00 movie
reviews but the thing about it is that
live streams it won't let me post a live
stream as a video like in a playlist I
don't really understand why that is um
so I'm thinking about maybe I should
just upload them like separately I don't
know I don't know you'll figure it out
yeah I'll figure it out one of these
days but yeah so it's weird because I'm
kind of finding like another audience
over there that don't know about the
main Channel which is crazy to me that's
crazy yeah I do have two other channels
if you didn't know about that scar Salon
which is my horror Channel and crime in
Memorial which is my crime
Channel I actually did a video today for
my crime Channel I'm gonna post it on
Monday and I might do a um live stream
tomorrow like I said about
fear no evil from 1981 which like I said
I don't remember who it was that
recommended it I didn't love it
but there was some batshit stuff going
on in that movie
though I don't know if the batshit
nature of it B [__] yeah okay made up
for the boring Parts but it was
interesting for sure yeah cuz I'm like I
can't believe I never saw this [__] back
in 1981 or maybe I did I just forgot
about it but I'm just like wow what the
[__] is even going on to this movie it
was kind of
like imagine 1981 Imagine The Omen meets
grease kind of right but with a little
bit of carry thrown in there okay like
it was kind of like that but but then it
was like overthe toop homophobic also
now there's somebody in there named
Ban's talking about the Philippines he
says that's really the way to go what'
he say where is that it's up did I miss
it I think name bwan something there oh
[__] keep going how far back is
this
um okay well I remember all this
so okay I remember that one I remember
that
one uh look at the
unicorn um are you seeing stuff I'm not
seeing yeah it's gone it's gone now
where' it go oh okay yeah I don't see it
man it was just here a minute
ago that happens
sometimes if you see it read it to me
because I don't see
it no her name is
Maly oh ma ma yeah yeah he go he goes
yeah yeah Philippines is the way to go
okay heck you can even buy a house buy a
paan whatever that is I don't know what
a paan is
palan and bour tourist attraction in the
Philippines 100 Islands xat go there all
the time Manila and MC tons of
xats that's what I've heard yeah I was
like looking into it a little bit cuz we
were talking about it a while back and I
was like H that might be something we
want to look into in the
future yeah if you have everything I've
been [__] hearing from the dudes that
are going there some of them are called
passport
Bros uh of different ages and um if
you're on a fixed retirement income they
say you want to go to the [__]
Philippines and just go there to retire
that your [__] retirement there's a
whole economy down there to capture
people who are on retirement
income because uh you know the US dollar
is worth a lot
there DVD Dragon just said Philippines
is crazy cheap amazing exchange rate
that's what I was
like I said he told me about it and I
was looking up a lot about I like oh
[__] man maybe we should think about
doing that like in a few years it's
beautiful and the people are real cool
there especially like in a few years if
we could actually sell this house and
like make some profit off of it then we
could just like [__] retire there and
like not even have to work if we didn't
want to yeah and with the money from the
we just be lazy with the money from the
house and then my
retirement [__] uh I'd be able to
finance a [__]
Mansion although I wouldn't even really
need
that I mean you don't really need that
it would just be me and you like be like
a nice house for two yeah you know you
don't need to get anything like bigger
than right I don't really need all of
that we just have we just we just have
the money to go out and [__] party
and [__] go eat out every night yeah
I would rather do something like that I
would rather have like a smaller house
that didn't need much
maintenance and then spend money on just
like going out and having fun and like
traveling and stuff like that because
like I said you know it I kind of feel
like some people like is like oh I need
this big [__] house with this and
that and the other get old fast we don't
use most of yeah like I said I don't use
a lot of it and it's just kind of like
it just kind of seems like oh you just
got to either clean it or hire somebody
to clean it it's just kind of like it's
a bunch of room don't you could easily
have a maid in Phil sure but okay I'm go
restaurant I'm just saying that it's
like yeah you could have somebody come
in like once a week and clean it so you
didn't have to do it but it's just kind
of like I don't know I'm not a big fan
of like having a bunch of space that you
don't use I would rather like spend
money on going out and doing stuff like
traveling going places you know what I
mean I don't need a big [__] house
I'm not going to hang out in there like
all that long I don't need a lot of room
you know so we'll see Ben says my
brother lives in Vietnam it's very cheap
there like him yeah I looked into
Vietnam too and that was like kind of
another
thing uh Camp guy said I can never move
overseas I have too many family here in
the US OFA I mean my family is in the
USA too but the thing about it is that I
mean I would miss them I would miss my
siblings but I don't see them that much
anyway
because you know they live a little bit
far away from me so I only see them like
a couple times a year anyway you know
what I mean so yeah I would miss them
but and I'm getting to the age now where
it's kind of like you know
my grandparents are all dead and it's
just kind of like my parents are getting
old and you know like I said really the
only family members I would miss were my
siblings who are a little bit younger
than me and I don't get to see them that
much anyway sadly hopefully I can see
them again in January because my
sister's coming back down and we're all
going to like we're trying to plan some
[__] for January maybe going to Epcot or
something but we'll see how that
goes
um Zan said Art Bell did a show from the
Philippines for a few years I didn't
actually know
that Zan said that Art Bell did a show
from the Philippines for a few years oh
he did yeah I thought he had a Filipino
wife didn't he or was she native americ
oh I don't I forgot I don't
know and then
um Ben said my brother lives in Vietnam
it's very cheap there I heard that's
another one a good one to go that was
another one that I was looking thing is
though is that being a being a veteran
they're going to adjust how much they
send you based upon where you go and if
you go overseas a lot of times in
certain other countries they give you a
hassle they're like nah you're over
there we're not going to [__] pay you
the
money it's a lot easier if you go to a
us
protectorate or you know what I mean
which is something within in the
American sphere and the Phil the
Philippines is a US
protector so Ben said Indonesia is good
too yeah
so you know and it's supposed to be a
lot better than say Puerto Rico because
there's nothing really in Puerto Rico
from what I understand the exchange
rat's really good but there's nothing
there well and I kind of feel like a lot
of people go there you kind of need to
go somewhere
that it it's kind of like that weird uh
Middle Ground between you want somewhere
that like other xats go to so there's
kind of like a community but not so many
go there that it's like gonna be
expensive yeah you know what I
mean so I mean we'll see how it goes I
am perfectly willing to like move
overseas a lot of passport Bros are
going there guys you know [__] uh
trying to have their first marriage they
want to have kids kind of a
traditional wife house picket fence kind
of thing they wouldn't really have the
money to do it here they go to the
Philippines yeah and uming I've seen
videos of these guys and they're just
like it's just like anything else it's
like a normal situation you know the
guy's a he's in good shape he looks good
he's got a real good looking young wife
she might be 5 10 years younger than him
and they're building a house together
and having kids you know and uh when you
look at the total cost that it cost him
it's a fraction of what that would cost
in the US the US is kind of expensive
it's too expensive to be honest with
you yeah Camp guy was saying earlier
that it's like he has too many too much
family in the US to like move over SE
and he said I have a married daughter
with a step kid and my son has a
daughter as well same town I've got two
kids a son and a daughter in-law and two
grandkids yeah that's one thing um we
don't have to worry about that we don't
have kids and all our family is old
getting ready to [__] like I said in a
way I'm kind of glad I never had kids
yeah um you know I know that sounds
we're not tied down cold or whatever but
I'm not like I said the only people I
would really M like yeah my mom is still
alive yeah my dad is still alive like I
would miss them but they're getting
older like I said the only people I
would actually miss were my siblings um
but they're scattered out spread and I
don't see them that much any I don't see
them as much as I would like to cuz I
really do actually like my three
siblings but other than that I don't
really you know I wouldn't really be
bothered so like we don't really have
any kids or anything like that so the
Philippines the food looked good they
said it's greatan everything kind of
looked awesome and it's just kind of a
tropical kind of place it's looks a lot
kind of like Florida in a certain way U
you know I mean the trees and the green
green
everywhere and um a lot of guys had more
than one
house like the houses were small yeah
and they only cost like $150 $200 a
month see love that so they might have
two of them and then they buy a
motorcycle and ride between the two
right like a little moped type looking
thing right cuz honestly one be on the
one of them would be on the water and
the other want would be more Inland so
there's and like the guy was living on
$1,500 a month but he was [__] living
like a king that's great though yeah cuz
I mean here two houses you can't do [__]
on $1,500 a month you can't you can't
have any kind of Life on that kind of
money in the US it's not enough yeah the
dude was in his [__] 60s and he had
all these [__] women in their 30s and
40s beating down his door trying to
marry him he's like I don't want to get
married you know they're like they he'd
date them and they'd [__] come into
the house and start cleaning and cooking
he's like get out of my kitchen but
they're trying to prove what great they
are God wouldn't it be funny like we'll
move to we'll move to the Philippines
and then like all these random ass women
are like coming in the houseing clean
like trying and I'm like hey I'm here
too hi yeah they're trying to well um
it's uh you know you'd probably be like
all right you can come in baby no I know
it's kind of like that it's kind of like
that in Brazil too A lot of the working
class women are are very much into
getting married and they uh they going
they [__] Flex the muscle of the
wife's skill of how good Cooks they are
well yeah I mean that's the skill that
they have and it's look man right like I
said everybody got to make a living yeah
I don't begrudge right I'm just saying
that would be super funny if like if
like we had a house in the Philippines
and like all these random women are like
walking in trying to like jump on be
like in Brazil you know what I mean you
get a maid right and US made also be
jumping on your dick
no nah you get one you get one that is a
worker and there's a
uh in a Brazilian house there's a a a
maid's quarters it's like a little
apartment inside the apartment and
that's where they live and they're kind
of like on they live there for free but
they're they're on like an allowance
right and then then they leave on
certain days they got days off and they
go back to their families and stuff but
they don't have a their own home they
live in your home yeah yeah yeah which
they live rentree but they which that
would be fine yeah they [__] actually
it would kind of be better if they had
like their own little kind of apartment
that was like outside or something like
that and then like they just come in
like however well we mostly lived in
apartments and in Brazil the apartment
has a little apartment in it called the
bites quarters yeah it's a miniature
it's got its own bathroom it's got its
own little sleeping quarters it's
usually behind the
kitchen and um you know and they
they cook and clean and do laundry every
day and you know that sounds nice yeah
and it wouldn't be much you know would
she clean the Cat boxes yeah oh yeah
they do all that it' be like a it would
be like aund it probably be like 60 to
$70 a week I love the kitties but I do H
Cat boxes yeah but they live rent
free you know yeah I mean sure and
they're they don't have children or
anything you know right they're either
young or old like retired women or they
young women we'll get an old one yeah
we'll get an old one so you're not
tempted so I'm
not I think that's something you know
want some 25-year-old hiding with like a
better ass than me like walking around
mopping stuff and phes in the
Philippines you get one like that be
communal property she'd be jumping to
bed with all with both of us and [__]
well I mean that would be okay but you
know what I mean as long as no one's
doing anything behind any back behind
anybody's back yeah we don't like that
we'll get one you
like then we then we can yeah then you
guys can go shop
together talk about what [__] dudes
are well yeah yeah that's what girls do
when we get together well it's true
yeah Ben says I've got a passport now as
a subject of the king I'm entitled to a
British passport took a lot of stuffing
around but I got it earlier this year
now I just need to win the lottery how
how old are you how old is he oh I don't
know yeah you be you can be a said
there's 30,000 americ Americans in Costa
Rica yeah a lot of Americans moved to
Costa Rica
um and then Ben said that's a good spot
but they have bad roads well I'm not
planning on driving a lot but I have
heard Costa Rica was cool too um Ben
says Philippines is full of Terrace and
ninjas and drug dealers at least in the
movies I've seen yeah no yeah no I'm not
afraid of anybody in the Philippines
well and it's not like that anyway no
it's not like that I mean zanada said
tell Tom yeah Cocaine Cowboys is coming
on Sunday I found a Blu-ray it's coming
yeah okay exciting co co okay so maybe
we'll review that okay all right I'll
review it if it shows up in time we'll
see we'll see how that goes yeah yeah
Tammy you guys don't know what he's
talking about tell Tom the cocaine will
be there Saturday okay if y if yall
don't know what he's talking about
because we've done a show about it
before you might be a new listener we
live in
Florida Florida especially this Southern
half of
Florida that's that Florida Skyline was
built on cocaine it was yeah that's what
Miami Vice was all about and everything
this was the entry point for cocaine
into the United States Ben said he's 50
he's 50 okay you going to be a passport
bro yeah yeah you need to go to the
phili cuz I'm 51 he's 54 same
age um the uh what I was I saying oh uh
Florida was really built on
cocaine all the [__] Governors knew
[__] everything you know it was
they weren't actually trying to stop it
from coming in it was well no part of
the economy
here and uh there was a a phenomena
called the cocain Cowboys and they have
a YouTube miniseries about them and
there were some dudes in
Miami who helped they facilitated the
entrance of [__] cocaine into the
into the country usually through little
airplanes that they bought and it was a
very sophisticated
ated [__] operation made by just
local guys in in
Miami and uh it it's a very interesting
story they they didn't consider
themselves to be dangerous criminals or
anything I guess you wouldn't yeah they
just they were just trying to make money
they just providing a
service and uh that's how you would
think they tell their stories and they
were I think the average person would
kind of think they were unbelievable
they were not they but they were
absolutely true they get pulled over
with all with a [__] ton of cocaine in
the truck and [__] warrants or
whatever just tell the cops go look
there's a million dollars of cocaine
back there in the [__] [__] the just
take it let me go and the cops would
take it and let him go dudes would get
take 20e sentences and then they'd
[__] help him Escape out the back
door and and nobody even knew that the
dude was escaped they think thought he
was still in prison but no he went back
home and he just living a normal life I
thought you were in prison this whole
time they caught him later what the [__]
I thought you used to be in prison 5
years later
no just and that was the way Florida
worked yeah um now the reason why they
called it Cocaine Cowboys is because you
had guys
from uh s South
America in the at the H at at the
airfields here dressed in cowboy outfits
[__] running around between all the
airplanes with [__] early cell phones
and walkie-talkies and [__] they were
like this big yeah they were like this
big and [__]
and they're handling all the [__]
cocaine shipments into the United States
through these [__] private airplanes
and they were just little bitty
Colombian
guys in cowboy
outfits bringing all this cocaine in Zan
said this movie makes you want to do
cocaine it makes you want to do cocaine
yeah Tom has done cocaine I've done it
did you just do it all time I've done
cocaine one
time one time yeah but they would but it
was shitty cocain they would have
[__] whole
pallets of cash millions of dollars and
they'd lose it and forget about it just
be up in a damn Attic in some that
hilarious they forget all about it that
you could like oh my God I totally
forgot about this million dollars that I
had they were busy I wish I had that
problem they had so much money they
couldn't spend it all I wish I had that
problem yeah they'd sell the house
they'd have a a safe house where they
would pack like oh yeah I forgot that we
like stuff five a million doll in cash
million thetic that sh yeah and then
they'd sell the house later on and that
person would find the [__] cash and
be what the [__] is all this and he'd go
to the cops thinking he was in trouble
you should have just spent the [__]
money forgot all about that money I
would just keep that I'm not telling the
cops about [__] I found like a whole
yeah I found a whole pallet of cash in
the Attic of my house I'm not telling
the cops about nope [__] no way I'm
going to sit there and do the numbers
how long has that thing been here how
long has this money been here how long
have I been here yeah how long has this
house been abandoned yeah this they
don't know about this money right that's
what all right this moneyy is mine this
money is mine now that's what would
happen that's exactly that's I'm going
to take all this money I'm going to put
it in the bank then then we're going to
go we're going to [__] we're we're
moving to
Philippines far away from any drug
dealers yeah exactly yeah so that's what
exactly what I would do too yeah I'm
moving under the country with all of
this money so bye yeah Zan said um
it has all the archival footage from the
80s you guys will really like it
okay yeah I'm excited yeah he said the
Netflix series is about the second
generation guys this movie I'm sending
is about the OG guys in the yeah see so
you're talking about the Miami Vice guys
from the Miami Vice era you guys don't
know if you're too young to know what
Miami Vice was there was a badass
[__] television series called Miami
Vice they had Don Johnson I mean it was
very style over or something they had
was name tubs it was Dom Johnson and
[__] name and yeah I forgot what
that guy's name is I'll think of it in a
second yeah and his [__] partner is a
white guy and a black guy they're two
undercover [__] narcotics agents and
they they're trying to stop the cocaine
from coming in and they're looking like
drug dealers themselves they're over
undercover guys and it was just a fun
little series from the 80s but that was
that was the uh very slick cocaine
Heyday and it was cool as [__] they even
sold John Johnson
razors and it was a razor that you could
shave with Phil Michael Thomas thank you
Philip Michael Thomas Tammy remember and
they had
razors Don Johnson Miami Vice razors
shave with that would leave razor
stubble yeah cuz he always has stubble
right so they had special razors St I
remember that had have the Don Johnson
stubble yeah then they had [__] uh
moose hair moose yep cuz they wore that
[__]
and then the [__] white supery pink
suits of peach colored suits and [__]
everything was a everything pastel
pastel color suits that they had and uh
and with Ferraris and
[__] and Don Johnson had the baddest gun
you could ever [__] imagine from the
80s it was a Bren 10 and Bren 10 was
basically a [__] American copy of the
cz75 9mm a [__] Czechoslovakian
pistol was hot as [__] but except it was
in 10 mm and we're not talking about
this [__] ass 10 mm that you have
nowadays in the full boore full load 10
mimer which was up there with like 41
magnum all right and he that's the gun
that he had Bren 10 and full [__]
bore 10 MIM
rounds they had to tone those rounds
down a little bit they were too hard to
shoot and it would break the brand 10 if
you shot too much of it there was there
was too much stress on it but uh yeah
yeah that was the day that was the day
man I remember those I was a kid that
[__] was cool as [__] back in the
day I had forgotten about the stubble
razor yeah the stubble razor when you
brought it up I remember yeah yeah air
Mose I remember like I said everybody
had to like look like you had to like
mousse your hair back so it looked like
super greasy MH like that was like kind
of a big thing it looked greasy but it
was dry as [__] it was hard yeah yeah it
was like crunchy crunchy it's like
[__] super hard hairspray and it was
a mullet basically brushed back yeah
yeah that's what you weree yeah DVD
Dragon tubs had a Jerry curl basically
well yeah he did basically it's Jerry
curl yeah DVD Dragon says horror movie
plot Tom bites your ass and you turn
into an alligator human hybrid she was
wearing this look black shorts little
white I was I didn't know it was going
to happen exactly because he sits up on
the weight machine yeah cuz I was
spotting and he's just kind of like come
here for a sec come here for a second
turn around turn around for a second and
I was just like oh what's going to
happen and then he bite me right B her
on the ass right she was wearing his
little swim and then later on he was
just kind of like did I leave a Bru did
I leave
a check and see messing with it some
more yeah you didn't none man she's on
none it's [__] it'll it'll change the
shape man she's becoming like a [__]
you would probably be into it if I
turned into an alligator human hybrid
you'd probably like okay no I don't know
no here help me with some of this we're
gonna here drink some of this
okay help me with some this okay well it
probably needs ice no no it's good it
doesn't need ice it's freezing cold it
just had
ice yeah Z said you're going to love
this documentary yeah he said I'm
looking for he said Miami was averaging
over 600 murders a year between 1980 and
84 yeah yeah it was bad I remember those
days I mean that's why they a whole team
y'all are probably not [__] up up to
[__] speed with Florida
but the whole Southern half of Florida
is basically Central
America especially back in the
80s one of their top drug dealers was a
[__] cigar boat racer he had this
[__] speed boat and they were
actually televising his races all right
this guy's be racing this [__] cigar
boat [__] going onund something miles
an
hour and nobody questioned where this
guy you know who this guy is or whatever
he was a [__] drug dealer well we
should note that there were a lot back
in the day there were a lot of cigar
factories in South and Central Florida
yeah actually Tampa is known for its
old um cigar
factories here it comes it's coming back
again yeah we start we start
coffe
yeah we've been sick for the last couple
weeks yeah maybe the last week or
so and it just like comes and goes and I
just start like hacking all of a sudden
he woke up in the middle of the night
last night hacking and coughing yeah I
heard
it I'll tell you what when we shut this
down I'm [__] starving man I want
some I want some uh you want some butter
chicken I want some butter chicken all
right okay so I guess we'll shut it down
yeah you guys had a nice night it was
real fun talking
y' we ushered you into your your weekend
yeah [__] Friday night and uh
tomorrow's GNA be Saturday yeah and if
you guys couldn't go out don't worry
about it we didn't go out either yeah we
go I mean we go out sometimes we didn't
go out tonight kind of broke kind of
drunk It's the [__] it's it's it's
the holidays and it's the holidays the
holid like I still got to like buy
Christmas presents and stuff but yeah so
Sunday I'm planning on doing a stream on
Sunday and I'm going to talk about the
movie fear no
evil
Monday okay so we'll either talk about
the man who killed Hitler and then
Bigfoot or we might talk
about the Cocaine Cowboys documentary if
that comes in time for us to watch it
we'll see what we'll see what happens so
we'll like talk about that uh either way
also Monday I'm putting up a new video
over my crime immemorial channel it's
going to be about the enal Washington
murders from the
1980s
1980s yeah um so yeah so I'm going to
put up a video about that on Monday I've
already done it I just haven't put the
video up yet but we're going to do that
so hopefully you guys had a good time
listening to us japper about whatever um
thank you for your super chats thank you
for hanging out with us this Friday
evening and we will see you guys well
I'll probably see you again on Sunday
but we will both see you again on Monday
uh so good night